morning everybody being 10 o'clock I'm
going to call us to order and open the
public hearing on HB
1387 relative to revisions of the State
Building Code and welcome representative
Maguire to
present good morning I'm Carol Maguire
representing maror 27 which is
the district for Allenstown Barton epan
hooks it and House Bill
1357 1387 excuse me is technical
revisions to the process of making
revisions to the building code board it
is a procedural bill it doesn't actually
update the code and it was a request to
the building code review board and if
you I the chair of the building code
review board is here to to uh explain
the details if you have any questions
I'll try to answer any easy
ones thank you very much are there any
questions yes representative
gr thank you um representative Maguire
this is a bill that we we review every
year or every other year to make sure
that our building codes are updated is
that correct no that is not correct okay
can that is the next bill coming up oh
okay sorry this one is a as I said it
some minor tweaks to the structure of
the building code review board and other
updates to the process not not to the
codes themselves thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank
you uh Philip Sherman building code
review
board
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak uh my I'm Philip
Philip Sherman chair of the building
code review board I speak in favor of
this bill obviously um this bill is
primarily uh what I'll call housekeeping
the term of art clearly of RSA
155a and just picking up some things
that uh we think can can clean things up
a little bit um I'm prepared to walk
through each of these disjointed Parts
uh in order and then answer questions or
if you'd prefer and want to interrupt me
as we go along because they do sort of
Stand Alone um um you know if you want
to take a brief pause at certain points
to see if there are questions that would
probably be helpful and if not we can
just keep moving on okay so I'll just
just run through the points uh generally
in order that they are in the bill so uh
currently there is an accessibil
certification that's required to be
submitted uh to the owner and this bill
also requires that certification which
is already required to be done to be
submitted to the building inspector at
this time the building inspector is sort
of left chasing the owner around trying
to get a copy of the certification to
see if it was ever done or not uh so
that's simply an administrative thing uh
the bill proposes reassigning one member
of the of the board of building code
review board from a mechanical engineer
to a mechanical or a fire protection
engineer uh fire protection Engineers
frequently have very broad background in
the various codes uh the board of Fire
Control includes an FP now uh and we
think that that's an appropriate mix for
our board without adding another member
to the board um the bill places a
three-year term on Alternate members of
the board without a limit on the number
of terms so primary members of the board
have a limit of three three-year terms
nine years total alternates uh do not
frequently they move on to board primary
positions the reason for this is we've
had alternates sort of drift away and I
believe we may have had one drift off
the face of this Earth uh and nobody
knows so this just gives us a check to
say are you still there are you
interested are you participating and
then somebody just reappoints them uh
it's it's kind of no mus no fuss uh the
bill clarifies the method used to assess
the cost impact of proposed updated
codes and brings it into alignment with
the method used since this requirement
was in place so currently the RSA
requires us to do cost estimates we have
no ability to do that and in fact States
uh that spend a lot of money on this
really are not doing cost estimates they
may take a sample case or something like
that uh what what my understanding has
been done for 20-some years now is the
relative cost impact is assessed does it
cost more money does it cost less money
or is there no impact at all which is
really all we have the capability of
doing and that's what the reports going
back sometime have have reflected so
this just talks about the relative cost
impact rather than a firm estimate of
cost um the bill proposes to eliminate
the need for a model code to be
published for two years before sub
submitting for ra
ratification um this is done for the
following
reasons we think it may take some of the
pressure off of some Municipal some
municipalities who want to get to a
later addition of the model code quicker
so there's a a bit of a tussle where
some municipalities want to take the
codes that are in the New Hampshire
State Building Code and adopt a later
addition of the model code and this may
take some of the pressure off of that
secondly in this day and age the entire
model code process is very open to any
interested party on the web you can see
everything that's different than it was
several years ago trade groups are very
active in the code adoption process
generally any large areas of
disagreement are well known before the
code is ever published therefore the
need to wait is is reduced the ability
to rely on other states who publish
analyses is maintained is they also have
a you know somewhat similar code
adoption process and that aligns with
the publication of their analyses anyway
so their own people need that analyses
before we do and and if we track a Rhode
Island or a Florida who are the two who
write the reports we we sometimes look
to uh they're sort of on the same cycle
we are and that that work is still
available publicly uh and the federal
government frequently is ahead of that
when they do the areas that they're
interested in analyzing
this being said we think that the
electrical code consisting of many more
detailed requirements than most other
codes is is a somewhat special case and
talking with an active member of their
code process who who's a supporter of
our process it seems that reducing this
two years to one year might make more
sense and given the publication cycle of
the electrical code that would give them
the ability to see it for a year before
it it comes into our system um and in
fact we can't move any quicker than that
anyway just given our ratification
process and and so on and so forth um so
it would not bother us at all if that
was amended to Simply change the two
years to one
year um the bill proposes that the
long-standing energy code compliance
form which is usable Statewide be
adopted by Amendment rather than by rule
in order that be in place when a new
code is effective So currently the
department of energy actually writes the
form for us and then we put it on our
website if we have to go through a Ru
making process there's a significant
delay before that can come into effect
and and in that case it it just you know
it always lags so by doing it with an
amendment you simply ratify the form
along with all the other amendments that
to ratify and they would have the same
uh same schedule as the codes itself uh
we think that's a more effective way to
get that that form out on the
street the bill clarifies that we're
that we are in the appeals route for the
election sorry the election the
electrician's board the home inspector's
board and the mechanical licensing board
no change in responsibilities occurs it
just clarifies in the statute uh which
currently simply refer to the RSA number
where those boards are buried as to what
those boards
are uh we propose to repeat
15582 Roman numeral 5 as it it's
duplicative it's it's addressed other
places in the statute uh we proposed to
repeal 155 A3 d a relative to biomass
boilers uh that was a big thing back
when it was written actually for a state
project as I understand it it's all in
the codes now it's pretty well
established uh there really isn't a need
for a statute to require us to permit
them because they're permitted by the
codes anyway and we've not heard any any
real tussle about that lately uh
likewise 155 a3b is proposed to be
repealed that addresses log structures
that was in a lot of state of flux back
in the day there's now a standard out on
how to build a log structure U and no
real need for a statute requiring us to
adopt the standard the standards in the
code
anyway uh then lastly the bill proposes
to repeal 150 5
A1 uh Rome numeral 4E again it's simply
duplicative with other other sections of
the RSA that cover the same thing um so
all in all most of this bill is
housekeeping uh in our opinion anyway
with a few material issues as just
discussed and happy to answer any
questions thank you very much uh
representative leas thank you so uh this
is a rela to page one line
24 as far as the cost so is it the
current current current practice you
said they're looking at whether it
increases decreases or doesn't change it
is there in the current practice is
there at least some idea of the estimate
whether it's minor or maybe
major the the problem with cost
estimates is if we said well I need to
put in that kind of a light
fixture somebody on some of these things
especially electrical items which tend
to be discreet they're they're a thing
you buy and you install
somebody can put a cost on that no idea
how many times that gets used over the
course of however long we might want to
talk about it so the cost to an
individual project is one thing the cost
to the population of the state is
something else again
um I think certainly some of these
things are obvious uh when there's a
large cost I mean you know a reasonable
person can look at them and and decide
that and the committee certainly take
that into account
uh so the our the Committees of our
board that look at a specific code are
the ones with expertise in using that
code um and there have been several
where they've said you know this is too
big of a of a thing to bite follow up
yes follow so do Ian is it where there
there is a case where it's reasonably
clear is that mentioned in the reports
currently or you know whether or not I'm
sorry I didn't understand that question
so um you mentioned something about a
report report coming out of this
analysis is or did I
misunderstand yes there and my apologies
uh the reports sit on our website and
I'm happy to get to this committee the
copies of those reports if you like they
they basically take the published
significant change booklets which just
eliminate the little administrative and
typo errors um and go down each one of
them and assess this relative cost to it
so followup follow up so my question is
do those reports um at least point out
the ones where there's a expected to be
a significant
impact U you know not a not a detailed
estimate but but that's that's perhaps
not explicitly okay all right thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you Mr chairman appreciate it
thank
you um just real briefly representative
Maguire are we sending this to
subcommittee okay
cool I have I have two more cards real
quick but I do
yeah
okay uh Matt
Mayberry
good morning good morning chairman good
morning committee members my name is
Matt Mayberry I live in Dober New
Hampshire I'm the Executive Vice
President of the New Hampshire
homebuilders Association so you'll be
hearing seeing us a lot
today the bcrb and Phil Sherman do an
amazing job I didn't realize how much
work they did till I started sitting in
these meetings and they do a great
job the New Hampshire homebuilders
Association is in disagreement with one
proposal it's line 26 and
27 it's the deletion of that has been
published for two
years what we've done in practice
Representatives is that we've let other
states adopt codes and we see how they
adapt to it if it works for them if it
doesn't work for
them and then we we learn from their
mistakes so we're always kind of a code
cycle
behind other parts of the nation um
along roughly with 31 other states do
the same thing and so I'm just asking
the committee to please
consider not um enacting the change on
lines 26 and 27 and let us remain behind
one cycle and let other states make
mistakes and we'll learn from them thank
you for your time today thank you any
questions seeing none thank you for your
time appreciate
it um Michael
Harrison
speaking in
opposition uh Fe just turn your mic on
there thank you good morning members of
the committee my name is Michael
Harrison um I live in Penacook New
Hampshire I'm a licensed plumber and a
member of the mechanical safety and
Licensing Board um the mechanical safety
and Licensing Board would just like to
speak in opposition of one section uh in
regards to the repeal of
1551a uh specifically to the appeals
process um it's our understanding that
the mechanical licensing board at this
time uh is not subject to such an
appeals process to the building code
board um we would not be in favor of
such a change uh we do we don't believe
that um such oversight is
required great any questions yes
representative Gera thank you so what is
your process right now for um that
wouldn't require this appeal thank you
for the question currently the process
by which appeals
of code disputes within the state comes
to the board is through um the
mechanical safety and Licensing arm of
the oplc
specifically um our state inspectors um
also through the public
um through a process of reporting um
those reports are investigated by
members of the oplc and then brought to
the board for um for
rulings follow thank you fellow thank
you
so why would wouldn't this process be
more expedient than the
other um our understanding is that this
process would be in addition to
hours so decisions made by the
mechanical safety and Licensing Board
could be appealed um to a higher level
um that process currently isn't in place
as we understand
it representative
goie thank you Mr chair and I want to go
back to I
guess is it on lines 11 on page two that
you're concerned with it is
I'm not correct in reading this that the
only changes were putting the words
determining what the boards are the rsas
are referring to the boards it just
clarifies in statute what the board is
uh I don't disagree with you but I don't
believe that mechanical safety and
Licensing was listed
previously yeah follow
up my understanding is that it was
specifically in relation to electrical
and Home
Inspection just a question I guess then
for the chair because I see only the
wording mechanical licensing and I can I
guess I'll have to pull up the RSA I
think it's just the wording putting the
name of the board in n i working on
it yeah but I need a it's a little bit
longer than I thought it was going to
make I need
a
a uh representative you got it yeah um
it it is um or
319c is the section for electricians and
C4 is the board so um as far as I can
read the existing statute the is it the
electricians
or you're concerned about uh no
mechanical safety and Licensing okay
sorry I'm going
153 I'm looking at it now and the
statute states that it uh also
establishes under RSA 153 27A which
it just adds in mechanical licensing
they're already part of that
statute yeah we'll certainly take a look
at it there's no need for uh you to sit
while we discuss it um we can discuss it
when we go into exact session the
mechanical licing session is there but
I'm not seeing the part pertaining to
appeals um so I'd like to figure out if
that's the case and maybe actually we
could have Mr Sherman come back up and
clarify for us but was did you have
anything else that you wish to testify
no that was it thank you for your time
thank you very much appreciate it Mr
Sherman would you mind coming up real
quickly thank you Mr chair U I'll just
read the section to you the way it
stands today the board shall hear
appeals of final decisions from the
board established under 319 C4 that's
the electricians board we just add the
name electricians board the board
established under RSA 310a 186 that's
the home inspector's board we just add
the label home inspector and the
mechanic I'm sorry and the board
established under RSA 153 27A which is
already the mechanical license ing board
we're just adding we're just clarifying
the label for um those of us who don't
have all the our essay
memorized um representative gold and
then representative L
us so uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question so just to
clarify this this language in the new
bill would not replace any procedures
that are currently happening changes
nothing it just clarifies the bill so
you can read it and what we're talking
about thank you yeah I found it thank
you representative lakas question
um actually at this point no it it's I
mean he was asking about mechanical and
1 for 327a is the mechanical license is
mechanical license and somebody asked a
question
about anyway they have they can conduct
hearings for disciplinary
stuff but um anyway it just adds the
name yep it does it refers to the it
refers to the RSA and we're just
changing that with the name mechanical
licensing so we found it thank you for
your help appreciate
it representative MC
Williams welcome back to
[Music]
Edna uh yeah your microphone please
thank you thank you so much it's a
pleasure to be here uh good morning
represent Rebecca McWilliams from South
conquered um I want to thank the bill
sponsor for bringing forward this bill I
think this is an important housekeeping
bill um and perhaps as a bit of a
preview of Coming Attractions I just
want to stress how important it is um on
the first page line
26 uh that we strike the fact that it
needed to have been published for two
years in order to review a newer version
of a code uh things have changed a lot
since we were receiving paper and bound
copies of codes to review now
everything's available online it's much
easier to access the 2024 code you can
search it and read it at your own
convenience uh and so I think this is a
barrier that has been holding things
back for us to do the review at the bcrb
so I want to thank you for your time and
just stress that point I'm happy to
answer questions any
questions
yes uh thank you Mr chair um do do you
feel that need to wait do we need to
have that time frame that some of the
others testifiers have mentioned a year
or two so that we can properly uh review
what other states have done or I'm leave
it at that thank you for the question uh
so as as I think we all know in this
room the code comes out in threee Cycles
so 18 21 24 uh so you already have the
latest and grest when you're considering
the current years's code pretty much
give or take um and I I don't think we
ever want to be on The Cutting Edge in
New Hampshire we we tend to be a little
conservative and we'd like to wait and
see 3 years to see what's happening with
the 24 codes before we adopt them so
we're currently not looking at the 24
codes in
2024 uh in terms of letting us see what
other states are up to that's kind of a
natural outgrowth of being on a
three-year cycle um I don't see us
proposing to adopt midcycle to try to
jump up to the 24 code in in a year
before uh 27 right so we're at 2024
looking at 2021 so we'll be at 2027
looking at
2024 um so I think it's it's sort of
like a built-in buffer and safety for us
to see what's going on uh and I don't
think that's going to change but is it
really necessary that's kind of for open
for
interpretation y thank you
representative BR representative leas
thank you um so I think you're you
mentioned that um we're always going to
be three years behind anyway uh is that
in statute somewhere or is it just
practice uh you know I would have to go
back through the rsas to really answer
the question as to whether we need to
delay in statute but it has been our
common practice to stay three years
behind as also most of the states around
us it seems to be sort of a New England
attitude but I can't tell you yes or no
based on statute all right thank you and
Mr chair if there's somebody here who
might be able to answer that it would be
helpful sure we can see if Mr Sherman
can he seems happy to thank you
represent appreciate your
time give us a little time Mr shman
we'll come up with
questions thank you Mr chair there
there's an intermediate step that's
useful to remember and that is that we
have a standing legislative advisory
committee on building and fire codes now
and some of the members of this
committee sit on that committee so we
have a a fair
um
obvious ability to know whether we're
getting off the rails early so I can't
say that there's a statute that
prohibits really quick updates to the
codes uh but there is a general sense
which we've heard from members of the
legislature and most of us agree with
that the the code is published on a
three-year cycle we ought to be adopting
things on a three-year cycle and the
question is how far is the off set with
those those two cycles um it's difficult
to write that kind of thing into statute
because weird stuff happens
Co right now the 2024 energy code is
held up on the model code side through
appeals it hasn't been published yet
whereas the other ones have so it's not
a a completely smooth system at at any
level uh but certainly there's a desire
on the part of a lot of us to to at some
point get on to some kind of an orderly
three-year cycle
where the outer world knows New
Hampshire updates their codes you know
roughly at this
point it's a bit of a Holy Grail but you
may get
there res us we just saying thank you
okay um real quick uh one question for
me um who is on The Cutting Edge what
what states are the quickest out and and
what's their time frame um in comparison
to the release of the
information I don't know the answer to
that question right now what I can say
is that I sense more of a drift in
recent years to try and get onto an
orderly schedule it may be quick it may
be slow but but rather than uh what a
lot of the States including ours has
have gone through where they sort of
stick with an old code for longer than
they wished and then they jump sometimes
we've jumped additions in order to to
catch up with things um so I think
there's a desire I I will never say
Nationwide there are states that don't
even have a Statewide building code yet
uh but you know there's a desire the
people that I talk to to kind of get
things sorted out so there's some some
sense of of of a repetitive schedule
syncopation if you
will any other questions seeing none
thank you very much for your time thank
you and um we have three
minutes uh yes
good morning Matt Mayberry from the New
Hampshire Home Builders once again I
have the answer to that question it's
currently five states that are using the
most recent bills and those are
Louisiana Connecticut Montana Nevada and
New
Jersey and the one thing I like to add
is if it's just presumed or common PR
practice then why we just leave it in
writing okay thank you very
much did anybody else wish to testify on
HB
1387 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing and we're up until 10:30 unless
you wanted to move to
exec no we got like one
minute two minutes all right
it's 10:30 so I'd like to open the
public hearing on hb10 1059 relative to
the State Building Code and welcome back
representative McGuire to introduce the
Bill thank you house Carol Maguire
representing marac District
27 and House Bill
1059 is
the Fairly regular update to the State
Building
Code so it includes the update to the
building
code mostly to the 2021 version
including the amendments ratified by the
board um will need to change the
December 8th 2023 date to January 12th
2024 because that was the last meeting
of the building code review board and
there are some amendments
there um if you want to know the
technical details of the Amendments I've
sent them out in very large PDF
packages um or you can ask Mr Sherman
who will no doubt be testifying
shortly the building code review board
did not approve the update to the energy
code that was a split decision and with
the help of Representative MC Williams I
have included or I have pres I'm
presenting an
amendment that updates the energy code
as
well I do not personally support
updating the energy code for reasons
you'll hear from other people but I
think we need to debate it it was a
split decision on the board and if we do
in update the energy code we want to
include the building code review board
amendments most of which are carried
forward from the current
version
and which were approved at the meeting
on January 12th so here is that
Amendment the only
real basically it goes to the later
version of the energy code which was not
recommended by the building code review
board and updates the date of the final
meeting so if you have any question and
I believe that that code needs to
be considered with the other
updates if anyone wants to have it and
i' and from the emails I've been getting
quite a few people do so if you have any
questions I'll be glad to answer
them thank you very much representative
leas thank you uh can you tell us what
the uh strike out of the last sentences
about that's in the that's in the basic
bill
um no I can't sorry but it is not a
change from the original bill it's yeah
I understand it's just in there I'm sure
Mr Sherman can
answer any other
questions thank you representative
McGuire representative MC
Williams
good morning again chair members of the
committee representative McWilliams from
South conquer um I want to thank uh
representative McGuire chair Maguire for
uh presenting the original Bill 1059 and
also the amendment um which includes the
energy code and uh with the few minutes
that I have to just give you a little
background um in my day job I work as an
architect um I work with a a very large
Nationwide firm that does architecture
engineering and construction for huge
industrial facilities uh some of our
clients include Coke and Pepsi kyoga
milk um the Kellogg companies we do a
lot of work for facilities that have
large freezers large warehouses very
small office space why is this important
because they're commercial uh and
because these very large facilities are
often large energy users uh to things do
things like uh chill and freeze their
products milk and ice cream as an
example uh so when we talk about the
energy code and when we talk about
updating all the codes in New Hampshire
uh these clients when they're located in
New Hampshire will be looking to what is
the code requirement for when I'm doing
either a major renovation an addition or
a new facility here in New Hampshire and
I would pause it to you that it matters
uh whether they are able to send someone
out and commission to make sure that the
freezer is not leaking cold air out into
the atmosphere and wasting money um as a
baseline in our code rather than saying
that's up to you you can choose to go
above and beyond the code and check to
see if the freezer is actually losing
its cooling out into the world um we as
a state care about energy use we care
about um our electricity lines and our
natural gas pipelines and having to
increase transmission and natural gas
pipelines because of increased
production and not keeping up with
Energy Efficiency and commissioning
would be a lack on are part of oversight
um so for that reason I'm very
passionate about including commercial
commissioning as a baseline in our
energy code and making sure that that's
something that we're fighting for when
we're increasing the codes to the 2021
uh because if we don't do that then we
as a state are simply allowing some of
these things to become normal when they
don't need to be normal we can have
someone come out and immediately
commission as soon as construction is
done and make sure that the building
envelope is not leaking so uh thank you
very much I'm happy to answer questions
thank you very much for your testimony
uh representative leakas thank you so if
we were not to um include this change on
the en energy conservation code is there
anything um in statute rules or the
building code that would prevent a
company from
specifying that certain additional
things uh beyond what might be in the
code uh be done as part of you know
their contract have the building Bill
thank you for the question
representative leus I think this is
always the debate that we have in any of
these committees can we do more without
making it a a law absolutely we are free
citizens we can always do more we can
choose where we spend our money however
when there is a public burden when it
comes to the public to pay for the
overall average cost of infrastructure
for some of these things by not
increasing the code we are actually
costing everyone who's paying into
additional transmission lines because we
need more electricity to heat and cool
our buildings and unfortunately we're
not re requiring commissioning so that
could be the natural outgrowth is a
facility that does not perform at the
level that it could because we haven't
Baseline required that it meet the
commissioning requirements so yes of
course we can always have someone
independently spend their money and do
more and often commercial clients do but
I would argue that there is a greater
good and there's a greater cost on all
of us if we don't make that the Baseline
all right thank you representative Manti
thank you Mr s thank you representative
for taking my question so if we are just
adopting the 2021 code to bring it up
where are we right now for the clean um
energy code in terms of what year cycle
are we in thank you for the question um
right now we're using the 2018 codes
across the board which includes the 2018
energy code but I would note that we
have um made an amendment to remove the
commissioning requirement for commercial
facilities in the 2018 energy code right
now so bringing that forward which is
what this amendment does still does not
Target the root of the cost when it's
spread across everyone who participates
in the market thank you representative
grto thank you so representative MC
Williams what you're suggesting is that
we address commercial facilities rather
than the because the energy code right
now applies to everything uh great
question thank you um the energy code
has both residential and Commercial
piece to it and you will hear plenty of
people testify after me on the
residential side uh we have we have
severely limited the base energy code in
2018 because of the concerns about
residential energy performance and I
don't believe that that really is a
debate that we're going to be having on
this bill today certainly over the next
three years as we look at the 2024 codes
this will be a Coming Attractions issue
but right now I would say the focus is
on Commercial thank
you any other
questions see oh yes representative man
py
thank you Mr chair so in terms of growth
you know we know housing large complexes
are necessary and the code can influence
the new constructions and stuff
similarly on the commercial side do you
see a huge growth in our state with new
facilities new
commercial um buildings coming
up um so you're asking me to put on my
hat be nosto Damas and say in the next
10 years what do we
expect no if I can cut it down to say
housing is a critical stuff and you sit
on that special commission too and with
that huge buildings coming up that is a
necessity need in the state with this
because it's a commercial scale for
building
codes would that
impact any housing large housing
complexes or or just commercial thank
you for clarifying yes um multi-unit
housing would fall under commercial
that's correct um and just to clarify
the record I actually sit on the special
committee for child care but I am
presenting several bills to the special
committee on housing so I'm all over the
state house uh but big picture I think
what our what our concern is here is
that um our commercial facilities want
to know they're coming to a state that's
going to have consistency and during our
last hearing we talked about how
frequently New Hampshire updates their
code and expecting okay in January of
every 3 years we're going to have an
update so coming up with that
consistency is important and also making
sure they know the rules so that when
they're playing the game and building a
facility they know these are the things
we need to do to meet New Hampshire's
code requirements um totally sideline
but also something that commercial
facilities are really struggling with in
New Hampshire and this committee should
know about this um the ability to
interconnect if you're waiting for your
solar panels to get connected as a large
facility it can take up to 2 years to
get approval from the utility and that
is just terrible because as someone
who's spending millions of dollars to
build a facility and then millions of
dollars to run it and then of course
hundreds of thousands of dollars for the
electricity having to wait on the
connection and not being able to net
meter during that time I think is just
terrible so that's personal but I think
that there are some things that we can
do as a legislature to remove
impediments to commercial facilities
seeding in our state thank
you representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman so are
these two bills going to
subcommittee is this carol
probably thank you very much for your
time thank
you Mr
Sherman
Mr chair members of the committee thank
you again um we're talking only about
the amendment at this point correct no
we're talking about the bill the bill
okay again for the record my name is
Philip Sherman I'm the chair of the
building code review board and I speak
in favor of this bill this bill proposes
to update seven of the eight model codes
included in the State Building Code the
National Electric Code is published on a
different schedule and we'll be back to
you next year with that six of the seven
codes published by the International
Code Council are proposed to be updated
to the 2021 Edition with the seventh as
previously said the international energy
conservation code being left on the
current 2018 Edition the board through
various committees reviewed each code
assessed the relative cost impact to the
significant changes and voted on each
code individually there was little
disagreement on the six codes other than
energy to move forward the energy code
underwent extensive discussions
including the bcrb committee members of
interested parties and I must say that
those committee meetings were wide open
um non-committee members were sitting at
the table and welcome to speak on
everything and did uh we had a the
Normal public hearing where a lot of it
was brought up again and then the full
board where the vote was nine in favor
of retaining the 2018 code and four
against
uh so it was a split vote but not all
that close uh presumably the people
voting against prefer the 2021 code but
not
necessarily that was not a recorded
thing uh the bill also proposes
ratifying the various amendments
approved by the board we have 79
amendments to the six model codes
involved the six go into the 2021 most
are carried forward from the current
codes however 15 of these are new
amendments
the new amendments involve accessibility
involving aligning the building code
with existing requirements of the
disabilities commission dealing with
recovery homes which is a newer issue
that's come up uh in the state
eliminating sprinkler requirements in
existing three and four unit residential
buildings we work with members of the
legislature and interested groups on
that accessibility certifications as I
mentioned previously under under the
other bill testing of plastic Plumbing
piping say that three times fast uh
building sewer definition and that was
uh our grease trap exercise two years
ago we missed one Amendment there so it
was to bring us into compliance or or
conformance with what the dees required
and again aligning the residential code
energy requirements with the other model
codes I'll speak if I may uh to the to
the potential amendment to this bill
which would require the use of the 2021
energy code first what is most important
in my opinion to remember is that many
having much larger shoes than I have
spent the last 20 years creating and
updating the code adoption process in
New Hampshire I plead with both sides of
the discussion to not collapse this
process while we talk about which code
we should
adopt secondly the bcrb has approved 10
contingent amendments that's my term to
the 2021 energy code which would only
come into effect if the bill is
successfully amended representative
McWilliams alluded to that each of these
amendments is simply carried over from
the current 2018 code no changes or a
couple section numbers that moved around
in the model code if an amendment to go
to the 2021 energy code passes but
there's disagreement on some of the
Amendments commissioning was brought up
we'd ask that you hold things for a
couple of months giving us time to
approve approve or retract the
amendments where disagreement exists and
come back to you with a new date for
ratification this will prevent writing
the specifics of amendments into state
law therefore at this time we request
the bcrb ratification date be changed to
January 12 2024 as mentioned by
representative Maguire which is the
latest date that amendments were
approved by the bcrb if necessary this
can be easily modified again Downstream
as we've
discussed lastly this bill proposes to
delete the last sentence in RSA 155 A1
Roman numeral 4 this sentence is a
Prohibition on adopting other National
or model codes and the deletion is
proposed as some of the necessary
reference standards are referred to by
their publisher as codes it's just
sloppy housekeeping on some people's
part the original intent of this
prohibition is I understand it was
generally to prevent the adoption of a
Statewide housing or property
maintenance code basically to prohibit
us from from adopting that U that type
of a code given the current ratification
process which includes the advisory
committee remember nothing at all that
we do comes into effect until the
general court ratifies the change so
there's absolutely no risk that we can
do something without the you know the
the approval of the general court um so
we prefer to just take that sentence out
of there because I don't think it's
needed anymore and there is a an
argument out at the margins that we
could not adopt things like the fire
alarm standard which is titled a code
which is necessary for us to have as
part of the building code so I'm happy
to answer any questions thank you very
much for your testimony representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman so uh
chair Sherman uh so you you heard my
question with regard to whether this is
going to a subcommittee as it usually
does and you heard the chair's response
that it probably will be going to a
subcommittee so the the the fine-tuning
at the edges that you're already
starting in on is something that that
undoubtedly will will be worked through
uh in the subcommittee do you have
colleagues who are not here today who
would be helpful in in in uh helping us
to get to the right result that could be
there for the subcommittee as well as
yourself I know you'll be there yes
representative Maguire is aware that I'm
going to be overseas during the month of
March uh but we certainly have other
people and I also wanted to apologize uh
I was asked to apologize on behalf of
the New Hampshire building officials
Association uh the texts went something
along the work the line of it's it's bad
when our full-time job gets in the way
of our volunteer work uh but
unfortunately the two two people in that
organization are both bogged down with
with day jobs today and we're not able
to be here just as an a side yes
representative GTO thank you Mr Sherman
during your testimony you mentioned that
there were some differences of opinion
concerning the energy code within your
building review code board and I'm
wondering did you address solely the
commercial aspect of the code or did you
look at it as a whole because
what representative MC Williams is
recommending is that we only address it
on a commercial
basis certainly both parts were reviewed
and both parts were discussed a fair
amount of the discussion involved
residential so we need to remember that
um the com the international energy
conservation code really is two
completely separate codes in one book
one applies to commercial one applies to
residential however that residential
application takes us up through three-
story call them apartment buildings so
three story commercial buildings at four
stories your commercial in addition New
Hampshire has extended those residential
Provisions to what I'll call smaller
buildings of other groups um and I don't
have the the uh numbers right in front
of me but it's the same three-story and
there's a square footage limit where an
office building a grocery store whatever
could be built to those residential
standards that's been in the codee now
for several
additions thank
you representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question did
you were going pretty quick did did you
say something to the effect that this
could be um uh that if we go with the
energy standards it could be more costly
to manufacture
buildings there there seems to to be
General agreement and I'm always
cautious trying to put words in other
people's mouths that The Upfront costs
of the new energy code are an
increase there's differences of opinion
as to how much there seems to
be there seems to be an understanding on
the part of at least some people that
that increas is offset over time of
course you only get an offset over time
if you build a building
so this does tie into the whole
affordable housing and those kinds of of
discussions representative meny thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um in terms of the code that
currently is in the books are being
followed is
2018 we are trying to adopt the
2021 uh to catch up for the threeyear
cycle so my question is between 2018 and
2021 we experienced a world pandemic did
that have an impact on our building
Quality Air energy all
those in terms of that came right smack
dag in the middle of 2021 the code that
we adopt would that get to us to that
higher level that we need it thank you
for your question uh I'm going to get
the dates wrong so perhaps the Fire
Marshall could help keep me honest here
the 2018 code was not adopted until a
year and a half or so ago two years ago
so that the 2018 is the date of the
model code but New Hampshire adopted it
here a couple of years ago um the 2021
code was heavily
written prior to and through through
through co uh but it was published in
2020 so it was
fundamentally solidified before the
virus started the co episode um that's
the general sequence I probably got some
of the dates wrong in
there any other
questions um I just have one if we don't
adopt the 2021 codes this year when are
they up for review again when would they
be
reconsidered
certainly the board would be permitted
to look at it again each year it's we're
sort of try to stay in sync with the
legislative cycle for
ratification um I don't know as there
would be a lot of incentive to do
anything until the next three-year cycle
comes up but again that's not statutory
and the board would make up its own mind
presumably
great thank you very much appreciate
your time thank
you um Katherine
corer the Sierra
Club speaking in
opposition
um good morning thank you for taking
my testimony
um I have um
my
and thank
you thank you good morning my name is
Katherine Corker I'm from New Hampshire
Sierra Club it's great to be back in
this committee and um we
represent uh 177,000 people in the State
uh members and supporters and our motto
is to enjoy explore and
protect and um we officially
um do not oppose updating
codes uh with this bill we just want to
update all the codes um and to include
the Energy
Efficiency I have
included a um a handout about the uh
cost savings associated with the energy
code updates um compared with the
Baseline which is the
2015 uh
codes and um that has a
the long and the short of it is um that
there are Energy savings for the
occupants uh of over $500
annually and and that's a pretty
conservative amount um so I in my
testimony I really want to emphasize the
occupants here um that the operating
cost of a home um is greatly improved
with these Energy
cost-saving building
codes um and knowing that we
are that the governor
has approve in
2022 approved $100
million to the invest New Hampshire
housing fund we are at a point where
everyone is really making an effort to
address the housing issue and I I
appreciate that um what I am nervous
about is building houses that people
can't live
in um and we haven't fixed the problem
um the Energy Efficiency piece
um when building a house may have
upfront costs
but if you don't do it you'll have
monthly operating costs on top of your
mortgage that will be a serious burden
uh for loow income fixed income uh and
the um skilled labor that we're trying
to help uh get home so
um it is it it really is a
mistake to not address the operating
cost of these homes
um so that was number two and then um
where we
could um allow our our last piece is
um the energy codes if they're not right
uh if the energy codes are not updated
then folks will have a house that they
will need to then
retrofit and I my dad was a carpenter
and he knew how to measure twice and cut
once that here you're building homes
that could be outdated and too expensive
to live in and then too expensive to
retrofit this
we have we deserve a high quality of
housing in our state and we deserve
these updated energy codes so thank you
um and that is my
testimony great will you take questions
sure any questions yes representative
Men py Thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question
um from your
testimony help me understand if I'm
understanding it correctly that adopting
the new energy code would enhance the
quality and clean energy requirement for
the commercial which is multif family
homes will also
provide the occupants of a much
better
environment in terms of energy as well
as clean air is it correct um I I am
more focused on the residential side
honestly and I um and so the commercial
question I would uh leave to
representative MC Williams um but
certainly With the Energy Efficiency
measures in the building codes it does
you know seal your house more
completely um and provide um
the house to breathe um not to like
totally um cut it off as an envelope but
um to allow for filters um to put be
built into your home um and also
thinking about Heating and Cooling there
is um a really important piece with that
as well uh so having that built in
rather than retrofitted later is
definitely way more
affordable uh doing it from when you
build the the home a followup yeah
commercial meaning multif family homes
that we're talking about more than five
10 story with
150 uh having clarified that um and
you're also addressing the need that
happened between 2018 and 2020 one in
terms of pandemic era requirements that
kind of brought to our attention correct
for the buildings and for because most
people lived in their homes right right
so that would impact if we don't adopt
it is that your concern I I think um the
advances in Heating and Cooling are so
significant waiting three more years
remember we're already three years
behind waiting another three years would
put New Hampshire well in the in the
rear view mirror than than I think we
should
allow represent
Schmid thank you Mr chairman so you were
indicated in your introduction that you
you oppose the bill
so sounds like you've got some issues
with the bill but you you're not really
in opposition or you think the bill is
inadequate because it's in what way well
um actually the amendment
addresses the issue that I have um the
amendment actually updates the Energy
Efficiency code so I didn't know that we
were going to see an amendment we
support the amendment thank you for
asking about that I appre appreciate it
follow up so uh the thing is you've
heard this is going to a subcommittee so
I caution my colleagues not to get into
too many details needs to be worked out
in the subcommittee not here so uh but
so you would be available for the sub
yeah yeah absolutely thank you
representative and thank you for uh
clarifying we do support the
amendment representative Brown uh thank
you Mr chair let me know if I get to off
topic here or if you think it's in
appropriate
so I I guess in my mind I never would
have Associated the Sierra Club with
homelessness and housing requirements
that's what I'm I'm remembering for I
think the Sierra Club is is there more
concerns than you're stating here is
there another concern that you're not
stating here that the Sierra Club might
have historical interest in that even
makes any sense um
maybe uh we support Energy
Efficiency and and that is actually our
core value that we're trying and and
trying to have access create access for
everyone to have Energy Efficiency
measures perfect thank you
sure yes representative
gold thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your
question uh is it correct is my
understanding correct that Energy
Efficiency and the Sierra club's
interest in it which may be similar to
abanaki people with 13,000 years of
stewardship of the planet uh is your
interest uh regarding impact on the
environment of energy and
efficiency absolutely this is a clean
air clean water issue uh that we should
do more with less um that that uh Energy
Efficiency uh I think
is should be a a pretty basic value for
everyone um I know we talk about
streamlining in in the statute this is
the same kind of thing if we could do if
if we could run our houses with less
pollution and less energy and less cost
I mean I think that's
win-win-win any other questions seeing
none thank you for your
testimony Sean tumy Fire
Marshall speaking in support of the
Bell good morning my name is Sean Tumi
I'm the State Fire Marshal thank you for
having me up here this morning um uh you
should have received a written uh letter
from me in the portal uh it refer
refences the advancement of the 21 codes
with the exception of the 18 codes the
department of safety supports the work
of the building code review board uh and
their work to advance the codes in New
Hampshire uh we hearing the conversation
this morning and the amendment we're
also um open to conversations for the
conversations to look at the 21 energy
code Provisions with appropriate
amendments so we're not locked into it
we just want to make sure the
appropriate amendments kind of preserve
the process so um there was some early
conversations about the process in
general the in the state over the last
few years we've um through uh the work
through the building cour review board
the board of Fire Control and the
general court and many of the
stakeholders I think we've we really uh
informally formalized a plan to stay one
code cycle behind um it gives us time as
we've heard to to to Really let other
communities look at their codes and be
the guinea pigs it gives our boards time
to really properly vet the codes it
gives our boards time to get stakeholder
input uh it gives our boards time to get
the information to the advisor the newly
created advisory committee on C building
of fire codes which is a legislative
advisory committee and uh you know I
think the important part is it it gives
us the opportunity to really review
things and make sure it's right for New
Hampshire um I think it's important to
preserve that process uh if we have to
change the language in the previous one
just a little bit the 2-year three-year
thing I think that might be reasonable
but it needs some cleanup um it sounds
like we're heading to subcommittee happy
to be part of those conversations um but
I think um moving the cords codes
forward building and fire is important
for our state IT addresses a lot of the
newer technologies that are coming out
um and it it provides for safer a safer
built environment um I also recognize
that there's a need to address
amendments um that are necessary that we
feel are necessary in New Hampshire
based on our stakeholder input and we
have the boards that I think have done a
very good job to vet those and bring
them forward to so we have a good
package um so just offer those thoughts
uh happy to answer any questions thank
you for your testimony any
questions representative gold thank you
Mr chair just want to say thank you
you're welcome that was easy thank you
for your
time uh Matt Mayberry speaking in
opposition to the
bill
good morning once again Matt Mayberry
from do executive director of the New
Hampshire homeb Builder Association and
I'd like to take a quick second to tell
you who we
are we're the largest residential trade
Association North of
Boston we have almost 500 members and we
grow more every day we add about eight a
month we represent
36,000 Granite Staters who work in the
Residential Building Trades on a
day-to-day
basis I can't be any more opposed to the
amendment to update the 2021 energy
codes but I'll give you data as to
exactly
why the National Association of home
builders has done research across this
and it's going to cost a new
homeowner average
$31,000 what they're going to do is
they're going to roll that into their
mortgage so at a 30-year fixed I went
with 7% I personally pay
7.65% for my home by 7% that increases
their monthly mortgage payment $26
at the end of that mortgage period it's
going to
cost to upgrade the homes for the 2021
energy codes as proposed $
74,0 that's a green energy tax placed
right on the heads and the wallets of
Grant Staters when housing is the second
largest issue in the state of New
Hampshire behind substance abuse
disorder
on the
payback I have the data happy to with
anyone the thermal envelope change the
payback on that in climate zone 5 and
climate zone
6 is8 years and 105
years let's flip out
to the installation
payback in zones five and six the
payback
to upgrade from the 2018 to the 2021
energy code Representatives that's 118
years and 115
years let's talk about the water
heater that's the quickest
payback at 24 years and 27 years
depending on which climate zone you're
in so you're paying
$75,000 for the Energy
Efficiency that you'll never get your
money back unless you're Immortal of
course or you bought your house when
you're
10 I have this again and again and again
of exact numbers and the exact
paybacks please do not accept that
Amendment you're
burdening I'm not worried about Coke I'm
not worried about Pepsi I'm not worried
about Sig sour I'm worried about your
constituents I'm worried about my
builders we have a hard time finding
labor and we're driving them out of the
state so you want to toss on $331,000 on
top of their head that they'll never see
their money back on it's going to cost
them
$75,000 at the end of this when we talk
about the state energy
codes and doing my research for this
again I had mentioned that you know 31
States operate under pre 2018 energy
codes that includes
California which operates under the
2012 energy codes the state of
Oregon Vermont operates under the
2015 energy
codes and the state of
Texas has operates under the um 2015
energy codes also Texas is not having a
problem recruiting businesses to come to
their state so so it's not keeping
anyone from coming to New
Hampshire but it's costing the labor
force to staff those businesses they
can't get them that's the
challenge
31,000 for those for that amendment is
it worth
$75,000 uh I'm imposed to the bill I
disagree with my colleagues and friends
on the
bcrb because I hear from the builders
who actually construct the homes they
don't design it they don't engineer it
the abstract they're in the field
talking to the
consumers and building the
homes representative you had mentioned
about air
exchanges and the air quality what we'd
like to ask the committee to please
consider is a few years back we allowed
five air
exchanges per
hour the state wanted to tighten things
up try to make houses more airtight we
all know houses need to breathe a little
bit you got to let some air Exchange in
there and we went to three air
exchanges we're seeing increases of mold
mildew respiratory
illnesses the
CDC has even Rec has has even stated
that we're making our homes too tight
we're not any exchange of air so we're
asking you to please go back to where we
were before for five air exchanges
please we experimented with three we're
paying the price let's go back it also
cost more money
because roughly 8% of homes their first
time out can hit three air
exchanges so what has to happen is you
have to go
you get the test you fail you have to
make more modifications to the
home then you have to bring out the
inspectors and the testers again to try
to get to that magic number
three 24% of
homes can hit the five air exchanges the
first time out and those are still
extremely tight
homes um one thing that
just an example of how what you have to
do is you can't put carpet down on the
floor before you do an air exchange
because what happens is especially in a
forced hot air system as you know those
vents sit on top of the pile of the
carpet well air can get through there
because you create a vacuum seal trying
to find out where it is so you have to
take the carpet
out seal everything up to try to get to
that magic number
three so
please help us make homes more efficient
more affordable get them on the market
faster let us go back to the five air
exchanges
please the other concern that we have
that we'd like the committee to consider
please are the issue of self-latching
doors right now under the um 2018
building
code doors close that's fine in
practicality and we've all seen them
when you have to have the self-latching
door so you hear it Go click behind you
there's a certain amount of pressure and
there's a mechanism to make sure that
that door can close
fully if you're older I also have a real
estate license and I've been a broker
for 35
years I have a woman who bought a home
in
napping the builders put in the
self-latching doors cuz they saw what
was coming down the
road first question she asked is how do
I disconnect
it because I'm by myself so what I to do
now she has to open the door going from
the garage into the residence she has to
open it up stick her cane in the
door to prop it open and get grocery
bags and take it inside she she is
fearful that the pressure of that door
closing could knock her
over if she hasn't placed something
wrong or doesn't wedge it open
correctly she goes then I lay on the
garage floor until a friend comes by and
checks on
me that could be five minutes it could
be five
days when I brought this issue up to the
bcrb and I asked the question Chief Tumi
was not there I want to be extremely
clear because I asked the question how
many fires start in the
garage because you're self-latching door
you're trying to prevent keep fire from
getting to the main residence how many
fires start in a garage in New
Hampshire no one can answer that
question if I was a
firefighter I'd be much more consider
about candles inside the house
burning and people smoking in bed then
about the whether a door has self
latched or not so we're in disagreement
with the bcrb on the self-latching door
they already closed
now the other one we'd like the
committee to please consider is moving
marac County from zone six to climate
zone 5 on the testimony that I handed
out to you you'll see a
map and marac county is right on that
line
right now it's the same it's in climate
zone 6 which is the same as Olive Co
County the state of
Montana Buffalo New York Bangor
Maine if it move down to if it moved to
climate zone
five that would help save homeowners
money while still getting great
instulation climate zone 6 for instance
in the ceiling installation
you have to have an R value of
60 if you in climate zone
five just a mile down the
road it now comes out to be an r factor
of
49 so it saves the consumers money home
builders are not in the business of
taking people's money we want to the
housing that you folks are asking us for
we're trying to get there
we're trying to keep the cost
down this helps I mean um I won't ramble
on anymore but those are the three
considerations we'd ask the committee to
please consider because that's where the
homeb
builders our 36,000 people have
expressed disagreement with the bcrb on
please and on that energy code
Amendment please in a time when people
can't afford the rent because what's
going to happen is those mandates and it
would be a
mandate will be passed directly on to
those who are
renting who are trying to buy their own
home and most people can't write a check
for
$311,000 so the com was made about you
know large housing it's going to get the
high rents are going to go up even
higher so please don't do that this year
please
please thank you thank you for your
testimony representative lus thank you
um a question and and a request for
information so you stated you're against
the bill but the question is are you
against the bill are you against the
amendment which adds the uh energy code
I am against the amendment because that
was a good
morning um so I wanted to add that in
there but as the bill is
written we are against it because we
those air exchanges are
important for homes the self-latching
doors we feel are important and moving
the climate zone for Marat County from 5
to six so that's why we oppose the bill
as written so follow up follow up so
those uh particular items they're in
they're not in the energy part but
they're in other parts of the building
code is that cor building code yes
please that's why was against the the
bill as proposed follow up follow up
yeah and you had uh you mentioned some
numbers on cost and payback for the
energy part I'm not seeing it in the
written stuff we have could you please
send it of course absolutely thank you
I'll translate all my little yellow
sticky notes
into and I'll have that for the
committee great away okay representative
Greta thank you so um I have a request
so while you're giving that information
to representative leus could you also
include the information for commercial
buildings because you mentioned resident
only and the amendment only addresses
commercial so your data doesn't really
apply in my view to the Amendments so if
you could include that that would be
beneficial um of course what I would
have to do is because we
specialize as on the residential side I
would ask Joshua reap at the association
of builders and contractors who deal
with the commercial
side um I would ask them to you know get
that and I can certainly convey that
request along and I think
in and on here ma'am if I
may I didn't see on the amendment where
it says just commercial it just says the
20 move the 2018 energy code in its
entirety to the
2021 energy code in its
entirety okay well the sponsor of the
amendment said otherwise so I'll have to
discuss that with her of
course representative
dlan thank you Mr chair uh
Mr Maybury can could you comment on your
organization's uh feelings about this
General move towards
electrification um that uh we're seeing
which I think is underlying a lot of the
comments today what what happens we
talking about an a perfect theoretical
World here what happens in the real
world where the community says we can't
turn all our air conditioners on this
summer and so you have to have to be hot
or we can't uh plug our electric our new
electric vehicles in because the because
the power grid just can't support what
we're trying to get it to do what do we
do in those situations and what are your
recommendations to how to deal with the
with the issue of of power grid not
supporting uh what the building code
might be looking to do absolutely
representative and thank you we're
seeing it now where you can't charge
your cars at certain hours of the
day especially out
west the energy has to get created from
somewhere
somehow we're talking about solar panels
we're talking about the disposal of
lithium
batteries how are we going to contend
with
that
when the New Hampshire Home Building ERS
Association and myself personally are an
all the above
approach because if you have a
transforma that goes
down you have a world of heart if
everything is hinging upon
electric you're starting to hear a
little bit about it along the sides and
at a later date you know we can talk
more about
it but when electric vehicles are in
accidents
they burn so
hot that it it's extremely hard to put
out that
fire if you're putting an electric
vehicle inside a garage or you seen
there's legislation before you folks on
electric vehicles and banning them from
parking
garages why because when they catch on
fire they burn so hot it's incredibly
hard to put out the those fires Chief
Tumi could talk more about what it takes
to put out a fire in an electric
vehicle but I think when you put all
your eggs in a prover proverbial energy
basket you're asking for
trouble thank you we have natural gas
and propane and you know wind and solar
and let the consumers
decide we're hurting them towards this
electrification I trust our constituents
let them decide how they want to heat
their home and power their
home but again please don't start off
with them $31,000 in
debt thank you Mr Shar and thank you for
taking my question I'm wondering
regarding the um zone change yes um is
that predicated at all on the trend
we're seeing in in a warmer climate for
marrat
County
the recommendation came from the US uh
Department of
energy and I think we all see how little
snow we've been getting so
um I
don't I don't
know I just wondered what the basis oh
sorry followup follow I wondered what
the basis might have been for your
recommendation other than just it it
came from the Department of energy and
so the US Department of energy so
representative I didn't find out as to
why but driving through maram
County you know as you see the Raging
snowstorm going on outside right
now the sun's about to break out um so
thank you yes any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time thank you and I'll get that
information to the committee right Away
Great thank you thank
you um Gary appet speaking in support of
the bill from associated general
contractors thank you
chairman uh thank you for being before
the committee today my name is Gary
Abbott I'm the Executive Vice President
of the associated general contractors of
New
Hampshire um I'm going to break my
testimony into two parts but I'm going
to start off with this I was around uh
in support of the Statewide building
code when it first got adopted in the
90s in the early 90s and it was in the
Statewide building code it was two codes
it was the commercial code and I
represent commercial contractors and it
was the fire code there were no other
codes as you have here today it started
with those two codes over time the
residential code all these other codes
ended up being put into the statute that
uh became part of the Statewide building
code we've had a lot of
success in that development we put
together
a building code Advisory board that
would look at amendments and changes and
I can tell you even when we did the
first code there were amendments
National codes are not perfect for New
Hampshire so we need to do amendments
one of the first amendments was snow
loads most of these codes and I want to
se I want to make sure you're really
clear most of these codes are set up for
safety and structural that's what most
of the commercial codes are so we
support the original bill because it
updates those codes with the appropriate
amendments that the building code ad
Advisory Board recommends and I look at
those the building code revisory board
is made up of experts including a
representative or our association before
that board that represents commercial
construction and he looks at those codes
and makes
recommendations those are the best
people Beyond say an association
director you want those
experts so I look at we're at a
Crossroads because we're we're up to
date 28 18 is pretty good because I can
tell you before we had a Statewide
building code we had some codes that
were 15 years behind so we're really
good today I just want to make sure
you're clear when people are talking
about oh we're three years behind I'm
like this is way better than we used to
be in the 80s and 90s before we had a
Statewide building
code so then I want to look at the
energy code totally different animal
that was added to the code because it's
not about about the structural it's not
about many of those safety issues or
dealing with how well your building's
built for a hurricane that kind of thing
and if you know there are amendments I
can tell you when on the energy
Commercial Code we've asked for
amendments to the 2018 code that were
accepted that would cost commercial
contractors substantial and made the
case before the building code review
board and we got that Amendment so when
you look at updating the code I feel
like the building code review board
looked at updating the TW to the
2021 and they yes we're not unanimous
but they voted not to update it why well
the reason why is the cost my Commercial
contractor who sits on there said I
asked them why why don't why don't we go
to the new one with amendments he was
like we'd have to make so many
amendments because of the cost now my
contractor representative also builds
affordable housing under the commercial
and he said the price tag that would be
added to it would make it no longer
affordable housing he would have trouble
so I'm trusting a person who's an expert
who's got to buy these products that are
in the energy code and what it will cost
he's not even sure some of the projects
would go if the standard were raised so
I'm really looking at the energy code is
a total different animal
than the other codes and hope that the
committee would support all the other
codes I haven't really heard any major
disagreement with the updating all the
other codes from 18 to
21 I say the energy is at a Crossroads
because we have some insight of what's
coming to in the future and it's going
to be the debate over like stoves have
to be
electric and the legislature's already
addressed the issue last year saying you
can't mandate it and that's why we have
amendments but we know the energy code
is starting to get into an area where
the cost and affordability is looked at
so that's why I say you're at this
critical
point I don't think the building code
Review Board in a month or two months
can give you the total amendment that
would need to be necessary for the
energy code I think they would need more
time if you wanted them to look at it
now whether you drafted language that
said you as the legislature would like
to know more information about the
energy code and why we couldn't or what
amendments would have to happen I'm fine
with that because I think you might want
that on the table I think today for
anyone to pick a given part because
there's a lot of components to the I
don't know the whole energy code I don't
know all of the components I only know
them When contractors call me and say
this section is a
disaster so that's when we go before the
building code review board so when I
talk to my representative on the review
board he's like we decided to stay with
a 2018 because that's a good code it's a
good energy code leave it in the project
owner's hands to decide what energy
efficient level they want to go if they
can justify it cost incentive wise
they're going to do it if it cost too
much or doesn't fit their plan we don't
want to stop their project I represent
contractors that want to build these
projects so they don't want to be a
hindrance but they also they want the
owner to have the opportunity whether
it's the state of New Hampshire is the
owner or whether it's a private company
so we're looking at the energy code we
support the building code review board
building code review board recommended
the original bill I think if you want to
go further with the energy code I feel
like it's kind of being slipped in
without all that other
consideration and that to me could be
problematic over over the next few years
if you don't look at all the Amendments
that should be done but that's my
testimony that we support the original
Bill we don't think the energy code
should just be slid in it's not the same
and it's a much different animal when
you're talking about Energy
Efficiency thank thank you for your
testimony are there any questions
representative
grto thank you U Mr Abbott are there any
parts of the energy code that you think
that you're commercial Builders might
find beneficial for the industry yeah I
don't think it's unan I don't think we
unilaterally oppose everything in the
code but when you don't want to update
the code and have so many amendments it
makes it useless that more than 50%
you're removing there's a there's a
conflict there when you start to do that
you're ended up writing so many
amendments it doesn't make sense but I
won't say that every part of the code
isn't a good thing I will add this and I
I kind of skipped it when that code for
2021 was done was before the inflation
rate mortgage
increase so whatever they use to cost
justify this is what happens in the
energy code they they recommend a better
unit for heating than what is allowed in
the 18 they all they say something
higher well they do a payback and I've
always argued I sometimes think their
payback is too long they might pick 10
years if you put the new interest rate
to it that 10 years may be 15 or 20 and
I start to question whether that is a
good payback period for that equipment
so that's part of the problem the other
thing that happened is with
Co is some products are less in Supply
today than they are than they were
before when that code was made not
everything is produced uh at the same
level contractors have fought about
getting certain types of equipment to to
comply with Energy Efficiency and other
things so understand there's a lot more
Dynamics to this uh energy code follow
up thank
you so a couple of years ago maybe two
or three years ago and my memory is I
can't quite remember what year that was
but we did look at the energy um
um codes and we did I remember make
amendments that included that do you
recall what those were well we we made
amendments and it would be in the
building code review board's items I
mean I was involved in one Amendment for
a commercial but there were other
amendments so the 2018 does have
amendments to it what I'm saying is to
put in the
2021 somebody's got to do a complete
review of the 2021 of what amendments
would have to go in now the building
code review board started that process
and they ended up voting let's not
update the code because it has such an
impact that's what I want to leave you
with that it's nice to talk about we're
GNA help the environment I get that
whole thing we all want to do that but
there's a cost associated with those
improvements and what is a reasonable
payback you have to look at the whole
thing thank you representative
Bailey hi I I'm seeking a clarification
I guess the bill and the amendment would
seem to be exactly the same including
the energy code and the only thing
that's different is the Amendments
applied in general it doesn't really say
to what between September 8th 20123 and
January
2024 are those amendments to that 2018
energy code I I think that would be best
left to the chairman of the building
code review board you know but what I'm
saying is whatever amendments we had
with the
2018 if you put in
2021 there are changes there are more
possible amendments we need to do thank
you representative man py thank you um
Mr chair I probably should hold up for
the subcommittee but I'll ask I was
going to make a comment on on that
afterwards but yeah go ahead okay um
just in terms of when you say clean I
mean the energy code is more cosmetic or
at more
costly but structurally it
affects because if we have the load on
the roof if you cannot put
rooftop solar and the loadbearing and
the snow amount all those things have a
huge impact on how we do the
conservation and Energy Efficiency and
you can't rule that out as a safety
issue I I think I just want to clarify
snow loads is not part of the energy
code so we're in support
of the current code or whatever
amendments to that energ that snow load
is so I don't think it's related to the
energy
code uh before we move on just a couple
of points of clarification uh first off
I would like to say we have four pink
cards left on this particular Bill we're
already running over I want to make sure
that the people who want to testify have
ample time to do that this morning this
is going to subcommittee so if the
members of the committee could really
gauge carefully whether or not those
questions need to be asked here or if
they can wait until the subcommittee
that would be beneficial also when it
comes to the Amendments um and chair
McGuire can probably clarify if I'm
wrong uh her Amendment changes the um
effective date of the amendments to
January 12th is but she wanted to have
discussion correct on the energy
component of it it's not part of the
amendment itself I asked for two
amendments and only got one and this is
the wrong wrong one it does not update
the energy code but we will in fact
discuss it in subcommittee we don't need
another amendment great so um having
said that I think there was one more
question representative go thank you Mr
chair and I'm not sure who's best to
answer this and I think the answer can
come to the subcommittee but for
everybody and you included uh my
question has to do with when would
looking at the cost impact on these
things um is the cost of the changes is
the cost of the harm to the environment
created by not adopting some of these
changes figured in and and if not is
there a recognition that perhaps that's
something this committee needs to look
at over and above what the building
profession does you may want to do
that thank you so much thank
you I apologize I'm not sure I'm going
to get the last name right um Chris
scard from clean energy New
Hampshire
awesome all right U thank you Mr chair
or acting chair thank you members of the
committee it's good to see many of you
again uh this is my ninth year
commenting on the building tax not tax
code it's tax time uh the building code
and specifically the building energy
code um so my name is Chris scogland I'm
with clean energy New Hampshire a little
bit about us we're often confused as a
trade group related to solar in fact we
have more than 40 members at this point
uh that are municipalities representing
about 430,000 uh residents of the state
which is approximately 30% of the
state's population that's in addition to
the solar providers that everyone
assumes we represent as well as numerous
manufacturers businesses and individual
members we also include among our
membership the three regulated utilities
eversource Liberty and Unitil and so we
work across a large number of areas I
personally work um managing a group
related to energy and grid issues um
some of which have come up today as well
as a group uh called Drive Electric New
Hampshire focused on electric vehicles
and then I'm very heavily involved in
the state's energy effic efficiency
programs principally New Hampshire saves
but then looking into how do we
integrate heat pumps with the grid and
with batteries and electric vehicles so
we oppose the bill as written and
support the bill as amended um with the
amendment today um I will save comments
for the subcommittee if we're hopefully
able to attend that because I know we're
running late there are other people that
want to speak but I would generally note
that uh we would encourage enourage you
to deeply litigate the testimony that
the home builders provided uh the
analysis that they did was um was in
fact an analysis of what the costs might
be but they were not specific to New
Hampshire the Pacific Northwest National
Labs which is associated with the US
Department of energy did a similar study
but they actually evaluated a much more
accurate depiction of what New
Hampshire's energy is like uh where they
included Electric
as well as oil natural gas
and uh I think propane and they
distributed that across the buildings to
represent how buildings are actually
built in this state the New Hampshire
Home Builders was a national survey
where the closest I think we could get
to New Hampshire was Chicago and then
Montana for the the homes they built and
they only looked at electric resistance
heat and uh natural gas we do not have a
significant amount of natural gas in the
state so the comparisons that they did
versus the natural the doe lab uh study
should be investigated also the $30,000
number that uh was shared I would be
interested to see all of the details
related to that because the best I can
see is that there's $8,000 that might be
attributable to the code but then
there's an additional optional package
that could be added in adding between 8
and $12,000 again uh I think there's
more information that we would love to
see our general concern is that we are
repeating a pattern that I saw first in
2015 in 2015 the building code review
board adopted or recommended for
ratification by this body the 2015 iecc
so the energy code with all the other
caches it was derailed by concerns
largely from the building community in
this committee we did not move to a new
code of any type until 2019 the
Amendments that were made that we we
keep calling carry forward amendments
were a part of the negotiation to kind
of meet in the middle so we could move
up to a more modern code but we had
missed significant number of years
between we moved from a 2009 code to a
2015 code big jumps in efficiency but we
had thousands upon thousands of
buildings that were built the problem is
we have What's called the split
incentive where the costs may be felt
principally by the builders and they
have to pass them on to occupants
whether they are renters um or
homeowners like myself and those costs
are something where the beneficiary is
not felt by the first party to Bear the
costs there is this argument that well
any homeowner or any commercial building
occupant can ask for a higher code to be
built to but I'm not sure how many
people are Contracting to have their
homes built um from everyone that I've
seen move into the state uh in the past
if they're moving into new buildings
it's all stuff that they found on the
side of the road when they were driving
around with a real estate agent they
weren't moving in and having designed
built for themselves so they don't have
that choice I also question the
expertise that we are expecting of
homeowners or any building occupants we
don't expect them to make choices about
their Plumbing their electrical their
fire code all of these critical Life
Safety things but when it comes to
choosing the right heating insulation
and um in addition to countertops and
interior design we leave that to them
but the problem is um we expect that the
new building code is about 15% % more
efficient and so we are leaving a
significant amount of energy savings on
the table and it does connect to the
grid it connects to resilience I
wouldn't look to Texas for any energy
code because as we saw from the storm
Yuri a few years ago a lot of people
froze and died because they did not have
homes that were prepared for extreme
conditions we also have conditions that
are more prepared I'm sorry I'm starting
a rant and I said I was going to be
short I will cut it out there look
forward to speaking with you all at the
subcommittee thank you thank you very
much any
questions have indoor
yeah not like the barbecue indoors thank
you very much for your time and we'll
see you at the
subcommittee uh Dian Dennis Community
power Coalition of New Hampshire in
opposition to the
bill we'll do um good morning chair
Simon members of the committee I'm Dena
Dennis I'm director of regulatory and
legislative affairs with the community
power Coalition of New Hampshire or CP
cnh for
short um the community power Coalition
of New Hampshire opposes this bill House
Bill 1059 um we do support the amendment
that was introduced and proposed by
representative Mick
Williams um just a little bit about
cbcn um we are a governmental instrument
mentality created to serve our member
Municipal jurisdictions and their energy
consumers pursuant to a joint Powers
agreement under rsa's 53a and
53e we're currently comprised of 55
member municipalities including six
cities 47 towns and two counties from
across the state right now we represent
about 30% of the state's
population last spring we launched our
first 14 Community power aggregation
serving 80,000 customers and the first 7
months of operation we saved our
customers $8 million while creating $5
million in joint Financial
reserves last month we announced a rate
decrease to 8.1 cents per kilowatt hour
lower than any of the utility default
Service rates between March and June of
this year we will be launching two do
more Community power aggregations which
will put cpcn in the position of being
the second largest power supplier in the
state um I share this uh to provide
context for how Community power is
transforming retail electricity in the
granite state and um I hope to connect
why um updated building energy codes are
really essential in um maximizing value
for energy
consumers cbcn supports increasing
Innovation through local control equity
and Community Development unfortunately
not adopting the most recent addition of
the building energy code as this bill
proposes would pass these costs on to
consumers in the form of higher energy
bills over the time that they own or
rent that home or building often these
costs are Bor borne by fixed low and
moderate income households creating an
unfair energy
burden as cbcn looks to grow and evolve
and offer additional value added
programs and services Beyond Simple
commodity of electricity to our
consumers having current building energy
codes will be important to maximize that
investment uh in a future with increased
efficient or beneficial
electrification um including through
electric heat pumps and electric heat
pump water heaters Uh current building
codes will will promote greater
efficiency comfort and productivity for
building occupants um believe as Chris
pointed out um it's far more expensive
to retrofit a home or building after the
fact then during its design and
construction
phase uh we also view the bill as part
of a broader context right now your
colleagues in the Senate are considering
a bill Senate Bill 437 that would make
it much harder for municipalities to
adopt more stringent building codes uh
the impacts of that bill would make it
virtually impossible for a community to
adopt the newest building energy code
which in combination with this bill
could constrain communities to the 2018
edition of the energy code um as the
floor
indefinitely uh also wanted to mention
to you that that New Hampshire has
access to as much as $4 million in
Formula funds through the federal
inflation reduction act uh These funds
would support implementation of the most
current building energy codes for local
governments the opportunity to apply for
these funds would be foreclosed if the
state does not adopt the 2021 addition
of the International Energy conver
conservation code um as as proposed in
this bill and those communities would be
prevented from moving on their own if
that other bill was passed um so thank
you for your time and attention look
forward to any questions and also
working with the
subcommittee any questions yes
representative go just quickly um was
that the
2021 code or the 2024 code that would
open up that that funding stream my
understanding is it would need to be at
least the 2021
Edition representative
man thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh does the 2018 code
for clean energy building you know it's
a part of the building part of uh
commercial development does that include
any regulations for Passive buildings
which reduces the energy conservation to
I mean energy use to 40% plus um are you
aware of that passive buildings green
buildings that built from scratch up
would
reduce um thank you for the question
unfortunately I that is a little bit
beyond my expertise so I would defer
that to one of my colleagues uh thank
you anyone else seeing none thank you
very much for your
testimony uh Ted Evans speaking in
support of the
bill morning could you turn your mic on
for us
thank you good morning members of the
committee Mr chair uh thanks for letting
me speak I'll try to be very brief but
I'm trying to come at this from a
different angle first of all I do
support the amendment the amended
version of the bill and uh a little
background um I'm from code enforcement
my job for 30 plus years was as a
building code and a plumbing
code uh official so from our point of
view anytime you have uh a difference
such as
all the 21 codes except the energy code
as an 18 code it makes things more
difficult as uh
practitioners um and and trust me
there's a need for competent
practitioners out there in the field
it's one of those fields that nobody
wants to apply for jobs as code
officials uh and so there is no training
no official formal training for a code
official so all this kind of stuff makes
it more difficult it makes it easier for
mistakes to to be made the way the
internet International codes are written
they refer to each other the plumbing
code says you have to do something in
accordance with the building code the
building code says you have to do
something in accordance with the energy
code and they're very intertwined and so
then it becomes a matter of when
something says they have to comply with
the energy code which one and which one
is the building code
intending probably the one that's equal
in addition but now we're looking at a
reverse uh code op option with
amendments and just I'm telling you we
want to make things easier to be in
compliance so that people like the Home
Builders Association don't complain
about inspections because the inspector
doesn't know what he's talking about
because we want the code to be this and
we want it to be that it just makes the
whole uh enforcement operation much more
complicated much more difficult so try
to take that into
consideration um as a member of the
building code review board right now I'm
in alterate but I did um serve six years
when it first started uh I was termed
out at that point for two threeyear
terms I went back on representing the
mechanical licensing board and I was
there for three three-year terms so I've
spent 15 years on that board and I want
to say that the process uh for
developing amendments is valid it's very
difficult we spent a lot of time on it
uh and I also want to just say that the
chair Mr Sherman is doing a fantastic
job and I think you should allow him
great latitude and trust in him and what
he's telling you and I don't think there
going to be any questions but I'll be
glad to work with the subcommittee on
this great that's been my experience
with him as well so any questions seeing
none thank you very
much uh Paul beus
Bemus in opposition
uh thank you for your time today my name
is uh Paul beamus and I am representing
ashray the ashray organization today
ashray is the American Society of
heating Refrigeration air conditioning
Engineers that's an organization of
30,000 members a global organization
that leads the codes in terms of
research codes are derived from the work
that ashr does in the research to
determine uh the effectiveness of the
codes
uh I am here today uh opposed to the
bill as it current stands and support of
the bill with the Amendments that uh
representative MC Williams added is
imperative that we move to uh Energy
Efficiency particularly the 2021 code it
is not that arduous it is not that
difficult we're talking here about
insulation predominantly and we're
talking about Vapor Barrier so that we
can keep these buildings uh cool and
heated properly over 40% of our energy
consumption worldwide goes to Heating
and Cooling buildings it's bigger than
Transportation it is the largest
consumer of energy and the largest
emitter of carbon emissions relatively a
big portion of that over a third of it
in our region is from heating
alone and uh for every kilowatt or BTU
that we put up the chimney uh we lose an
equal amount out the sides of our
buildings sealing them is important it's
extremely important particularly as we
move to
electrification by moving from fossil
fuels to heat pump type of source you
get an advantage of at least four to one
over your existing fossil fuel base
system at least and often much higher
and it does both Heating and
Cooling however to make them effective
the building envelope its instulation
its Vapor Barrier must be secure it must
be complete the 2021 code moves in that
direction the 2018 code does not I would
caution you not to consider this just as
a return on investment or to look at it
just from a first cost point of view
it's easy for a builder to look at it
from first cost point of view because
they leave the site and go on to the
next project it is the homeowner or the
building owner that gets burdened with
the operating cost of these buildings
for heating and cooling over the life of
the building which we hope to be at
least 50
years I personally own a software
company that does mathematical modeling
I am an expert in building science I
have an undergraduate in mechanical
engineering a graduate degree in
electrical engineering and a master's in
business I've been in the building
Sciences for over 30 years expert in
mathematical modeling particularly as it
pertains to Thermal for highperformance
buildings and I can tell you from the
research done by the Builders
Association the study that was done
appears to have been a predone
conclusion or predetermined conclusion I
can tell you from my expertise in
mathematical modeling that you can make
a mathematical model say anything you
want by changing the assumptions for
example I find it interesting they used
2019 Energy prices and 2021 construction
prices they did not over time look at
the cost of energy increase over time
over the amortization period they looked
at uh nor did they consider a change in
technology from say fossil fuels to heat
pumps which would I said again give you
an efficiency Improvement at least four
to eight times that of fossil fuels but
I want to bring up another issue here
that hasn't been spoken about and that
is quality that is the human environment
the quality of the environment in which
we live in human Comfort can be measured
and analytically we can measure it very
accurately we as humans like an
environment that is roughly 40 to 60%
relative humidity for example we like
temperature where the gradient the
change in temperature across a given
environment like a room uh tends to be
very low and low air velocity as well
these are quantifiable numbers that we
can predict very accurately the 2020
building code uh helps to achieve a good
healthy indoor environment air quality
environment air quality has become quite
important uh as you well know due to the
Co pandemic and compliance to these
building specifications is extremely
important for Healthy Living we as
humans live in these homes and we work
in these buildings making them energy
efficient saves operating cost over time
and reduces carbon emission to our
planet which is becoming increasingly uh
a problem furthermore the it reduces by
reducing the cost associated with
operating the building uh there is more
available to the homeowner as
discretionary spending and banking or
institutions are beginning to notice
this and offer lower cost loans uh now
and lower interest rates associated with
Green Building
design so I would encourage you not to
just look at first cost and to study
carefully any any study that's been
brought to you that looks at
amortization over time with a careful
eye the 2021 codes are extremely
important to us not just for energy
reasons but also uh human Comfort
reasons which is uh important uh to all
occupants whether they commercial or
residential questions thank you for your
testimony yes representative
man sorry I had my microphone on it
happens us yeah um thank you you bring
out two important aspects of uh
commercial buildings and clean energy
safe comfort so does 2021 code include
the passive green buildings which
addresses the
energy conservation as well as comfort
and clean air in the building uh thank
you for your question no uh passive
house has a higher level uh passive
house uh has a specification of for
example 6 uh air changes so passive
house is very tight uh and is above the
20 point code uh but since you've
brought up passive house I will tell you
that the heating and cooling load of a
passive house design is so low that uh
you can reduce the capital cost
associated with your heating and cooling
equipment to the point where it is quite
small and putting a solar array in your
home can make your home actually
positive with respect to energy
production to the point where it could
for example power your automobile the
National Institutes of science and
technology did an experiment in Bethesda
in the Maryland area and built a home
not even to passive house but to 2021
standards and put a 10 kilowatt uh array
on the top on the roof of porch roof
it's a beautiful home if I could show it
to you I would it's beautiful I can send
you the report first year of operation
they exceeded the energy consumption of
the home by
7% enough to power the autom that was
parked in the
garage this is not science fiction this
has been proven to be able to be done
what is important is that we make the
investment during the build sequence if
we don't do it up front the cost to do
it later is at least a factor of 10 very
hard to go in and reinsulate a slab
after it's been poured or reinsulate
concrete walls after they've been poured
if you don't do it up front you pay
throughout the life of the building an
increased energy costs and if you ever
wanted to retrofit the building it would
be at least a factor of 10 more to do so
so I encourage you to think about these
as we go forward I again support the
recommendation the amendment that uh
representative MC Williams has put
forward opposed the bill in its current
form
represent are you going to be available
for the subcommittee M Mr would
certainly make myself available at any
committee you would like me to be at yes
for sure thank you any other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony um did anybody else wish to
speak on HB
1059 saying none I will close the public
hearing on HB 1059 and welcome the chair
back to the
table
I do wish to apologize to the committee
for bringing the wrong Amendment and to
rep thank representative Bailey for his
skills in in noticing that because I
didn't
okay
well I wanted to to thank representative
Bailey for actually reading the
amendment all right uh open the hearing
for cacr 11 and call Representative
lungren thank you madam chair um uh
representative David lungren from
Londoner Rockingham 16
uh I totally support this bill uh it's a
very easy Bill what it does is
essentially
uh allow someone to run for Sheriff as
long as uh they haven't reached the age
of 70 if they reach the age of 70 during
their term um unfortunately they're
supposed to resign so uh I think if we
extend it so that they can finish their
term out it will be beneficial to all of
us and um that's pretty much it I want
to make sure you guys break for lunch
so thank you we appreciate your
consideration um any questions are there
any questions from the committee yeah
represent leus um my only question is is
there anything that limits uh how long
the term of a sheriff can be so if they
turn 70 shortly after uh the beginning
of their term what's the oldest they
could be and still serve if this pass if
if they're 70 in their uh first year of
of um election of sheriff then they have
three more years and they're
done follow up or in some cases two
years depending on that's I'm sorry
thank is there something that limits the
maximum the length of their term can be
and where is
that the AG
is statute or rules or the Constitution
not that I know okay thank you thank
you any other questions thank you very
much thank you representative
Wallace thank you madam chair for the
record I'm representative Scott Wallace
Rockingham County District 8 the town of
Danville I also sit on the uh Rockham
county executive committee and in my
role is chair of the uh Sheriff's Office
uh subcommittee rocket him county has
had some issues over the past decade
with uh keeping the sheriff's office
with some continuity um we had a Sheriff
pass away in 2015 necessitating the
county delegation to appoint a sheriff
who was only able to serve for one term
because he was aged out uh and that's
created a little bit of a um continuity
problem with the with the department so
this simple fix would allow a sheriff
who attains the age of who turn 70
during his term to continue the term
it's very simple we'd like to see that
happen and we ask for this uh committee
to pass this I'd be happy to answer any
questions representative
sh thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um how many counties
do you know um have a four-year term for
their Sheriff as opposed to two I
believe there's two counties at this
point just one okay I stand corrected
one Rockingham County at this
point okay any other questions thank you
for answering that question I'm sure it
was ort the rest of us Charles
mahos thank you chairman McGuire and
members of this committee for for me to
be here today to speak about this bill
that we're trying to put in my name is
Chuck mes I'm the high Sheriff of
Rockingham County in 2022 the state leg
legislator passed a bill that would
change the term of office for Rockham
County elected officials from a 2-year
to a 4-year term as a result should I be
reelected in my next cycle I will reach
the
age of of 70 during the middle of my
term so I would only be able to fulfill
that term for two
years currently I ask you support this
change in the Constitution the the
change would permit any Sheriff who
attains the age of 70 years to finish
out that current term as the official du
duly elected by the voters pass of that
Amendment would allow the voters of the
state to weigh on this critical change
the only other person that is restricted
by this age is that of Judges they
retire retire at or prior to the age of
70 however it is common practice that
judges return to the bench after
retirement to assist a Judicial brand
I would classify this as a loophole in
the age requirement which is not
afforded to
sheriffs in closing I I ask you humbly
to pass this legislation allow the
voters of the state to determine whether
a change in age is warranted but I'm
going to go off what I wrote Because I
feel that I need to speak by my heart um
I was elected in 2018 as the high
Sheriff of Rockingham County I'm very
passionate about what I've done we are
fortunate in enough to have Sheriff
Downing as our sheriff and as everybody
knows that he passed away from cancer uh
Sheriff Downing LED that department he
started changing the Dynamics of that
Sheriff's Office to a full police
organization we're lucky to get Mike
hero uh elected by the delegation and
Mike fulfilled one term but Mike didn't
run a second term because of the age
requirement so he would have been one
year short of
you know one year short which means if
this bill was put into effect that he
could run now it comes to me because we
have a four-year term even if I had a
two-year term right I would I would I
would want to run and if I had to resign
I would resign because for six years now
I've battled the opio crisis in
Rockingham County and the state and I'm
getting drugs off the street I've turned
it into a full-fledged police
organization I've built one of the most
effective drug units in the state of New
Hampshire we want to continue on that
path and just getting this bill passed
will give me four years another four
years where I can get it done now I
don't want to be Sheriff when I'm 75 but
I want to I want to make sure that I
fulfill the promises I made to the
taxpayers and the voters of the state
about getting these illegal drugs off
the street I think it's a good bill I
think it will if other sheriff's offic I
know some other sheriff's officers are
trying to get a you know a 4-year term
which they should get cuz two years
isn't enough time to get anything done
so I appreciate you letting me listen to
me today and I thank you for your time
are there any questions representative
gold just um to get clarification on a
question that representative luk leus
asked earlier if you a if this passed
and you were able to continue your term
to the end and you were over age 70
would that mean that you could not run
for reelection because you were too old
once I'll be too old so once if this
bill passes the the voters elect me to
be Sheriff again then I'll be able to
stay on till I'm 72 but I'm not going to
be able to I won't be able to run again
because it's a 70 age
Gap representative
G thank you what are the requirements
for running for sheriff in New Hampshire
what are the requirements yeah there is
no the county the county there's no you
can be you don't have to live in the
county you don't have to you can you can
youbody you can be a plumber you can be
electrici you could be a guy pumping gas
at a gas station to run for Sheriff
there's no College requirements which is
it's just unfortunate I mean I came to
this job as a part-time deputy sheriff
but I'm also a businessman I own my own
business in London area New Hampshire so
I mean I brought close to 40 years with
the business experience plus law
enforcement experience working for the
Rockingham County Sheriff's Office and
four years with the New Hampshire State
Police but there are no requirements for
Sheriff that's why it's very important
that we try to listen the sheriffs in
the state are all hardworking men and
and and and you when I first took over
this job two years the first two years
you're you're you're getting your feet
wet you do you know you're you're trying
to get as much as you're done when we
got this four-year term it's like this
is like phenomenal because now I can
concentrate on my job taking drugs off
the street being community policing
right getting out there to do what we
can do to assist our local law
enforcement Partners the state police
right now are down 80 Troopers in this
state so or close to 80 Troopers but
we're there helping out the state police
all these small police departments can't
get police officers so we're there to
support our local police departments in
investigations are backing them up are
working their their towns that's what we
do as as far as the experience goes with
this job anybody can run for Sheriff but
you want to try to keep the the right
people on the right job I've been doing
a great job all the sheriff's been doing
a great job it just it's just with that
70-year cap it's it's it's hard to
predict the future you know what I mean
about about this job I hope that answers
your
question actually it doesn't follow up
because if there's a cap on age that's a
requirement so does are you required to
live in the county I don't care about
your qualifications I just want I have
to live in Rockingham County and what
else to run for Sheriff that's it that's
it so why don't we say instead of this
why don't we say that in order to run
for County Sheriff you can't be 70
during your
term I don't understand the question
that would limit the age well I mean it
would be nice to get rid of the age
requirement
no I'm saying that you cannot run if
you're going to turn 70 within your term
that would be a different way of
phrasing what you're doing then you're
sure changing you're sure changing me
two
years I could run but then I would have
to
resign I'd have to
resign statute says you're out of
office correct you're done I'm done so
so when I turn when I turn 68 years old
right I'm planning on running if this
Bill gets passed or not I'm planning on
running and then I'll resign and then
the delegation will pick the next
Sheriff
okay thank you for your testimony any
other questions I will say that 70 isn't
as old as it used to be no you know and
to be honest with you I don't want to be
Sheriff when I'm 75 years old I just
want to F feel my obligation to the
voters of Rockingham County thank you
thank you others all right is any anyone
else who wishes to
testify not seeing anybody I'll close
the public hearing thank you for your
time and we will resume at
1:30 with archival
records
yep yes I mean we we had a um I had a
constituent run for marac County Sheriff
because he he was a deputy in Rockingham
County and he had but he lived in marrat
County so he had to run in
Mar that's
it
e
okay welcome
back I'm introduc opening the hearing on
House Bill 1433 and I call on
representative
goalie thank you madam chair and members
of the committee uh for the record
representative Jeff goalie representing
Hillsboro 21 uh town of uh city of
Manchester W one uh here to introduce
House Bill 1433
FN uh um permitting the Secretary of
State to accept historical records and
objects and donations for their
maintenance um this was at the request
of the Secretary of State's office
um after going through uh some of the
things they have um accepting donations
for a number of items um it was realized
that unlike many other departments here
in the state of New Hampshire uh they
don't have the statutory authority to
accept these or actually uh have in
place a way for uh accepting donations
for um the documents or anything else
they may receive or to receive outside
money for uh also maintaining these
articles um and also if I may Madam
chair there was an amendment uh
submitted to OS last week at the request
of secretary state's office that is not
ready
yet no surprise um but I was just over
there and they said it's urgent they'll
have it to us in probably 15 20 minutes
that's well after this hearing but what
that does is um put two positions into
the Secretary of State's office for the
maintenance of this division um which uh
they will talk about
um when they come up um it's money they
already have available to put uh put
into position um they're not looking for
added Monies um so if I may I'll let
them speak to this bill and speak to
that Amendment um because they're well
versed in
it thank you uh representative uh leus
just a quick question so just to be
clear this allows them to accept things
but it doesn't require them to accept
anything donated to them is that correct
correct and and follow up um is there
any requirement that they anything
they've accepted they have to keep for
the rest of Eternity or can they choose
not to at some point I believe they have
their choice to do what they want but
I'm sure they can answer that for you
thanks but like I said many other state
agencies already have this in place that
this option and they going through their
records found out that it's not in their
statute so they were asking for it all
right thank you other questions thank
you very much representative
buly um Aon
Hennessy
good afternoon everyone I am Aaron
Hennessy I am the deputy secretary of
state good afternoon everyone I'm Ashley
Miller I'm the New Hampshire State
archist okay I'm here to testify in
favor of hb1
1433 the division of archives and
Records management has two principal
functions the first is to preserve
documentation of the history of New
Hampshire state government institutions
making them available and accessible to
the public uh we also assist state
agencies with the efficient and proper
management of their records and with
that service offer them storage space
for their records in late February 2023
I started as the New Hampshire State
archist and since then I've been working
to clean up and update all of our
policies and procedures included any
needed statute changes this bill
formally allows us to accept donations
of archival materials and any potential
monetary donations that may accompany
them the amendment offered by
representative goalie allows us to offer
a higher labor grade for for two of our
entry level but critical operations
records Clerk positions which due to the
lapse in vacancies we already have
covered I just want to end this with I
recently had a representative um visit
for her birthday to come check out all
of the awesome things we have at
archives and would encourage all of you
to reach out and come check out archives
I'd be happy to give you a tour um thank
you to the committee for the opportunity
to speak and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you representative
Schmidt and man py and then sh
it having recently been over at the
archive and not for the first
time was standing in the main hall of
the archives and admiring two
portraits which are on on that wall and
maybe I could ask the archist to speak
to those two paintings because every one
of us should should see that when we get
a chance thank you for your question
representative Schmidt um are you
referring to the painting in the
research room or in the front lobby the
big lovely mural the lobby the lobby
where I met you yes um there is a big
beautiful mural of New Hampshire
Wilderness right when you walk into the
front lobby of the archives there's also
two historic desks there
too thank
you represent man py thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
so is this archive exhibit open to
public or just uh officials thank you
for your question it is open to everyone
everything we have at The Archives
that's open to the public I should say
um these are the people's records so we
encourage everyone to come take a look
at them thank you so have Shu and then
Brown thank you madam chair um first I
would like to thank Miss Miller for her
help uh in obtaining some documents to
celebrate the 200th anniversary of marck
County thank you for providing that but
my question is um I've been there many
times and I know that you already have
an extensive collection um how was
archives able to receive those without
this uh particular
statute thank you for your question so
our archival materials come from a
variety of places um and we have
received donations in the past um this
just formally allow ows us to do so now
we do have the right to say no to
donations and things you know that we
already have but that would be at my
discretion okay represent Brown and then
lus uh thank you madam chair and thanks
for being here taking my question so you
have two positions that haven't been
filled and that's what these two B
positions are going to take that I
understand that thank you for your
question we have one position that's
currently open um it's open because of a
recent retirement but because of the
various vacancies we've had throughout
the year giving them the pay bump um is
already covered by money we have okay
follow up follow so will this add
permanently add to your staff
number-wise
no okay thank
you in that case if we do have an
amendment to create two new positions at
a higher labor grade I trust we will
also abolish the lower labor grade
positions okay I see you're agreeing we
will we'll put that on the checklist
thank you representative leus thank you
uh two questions one is uh the one IID
asked uh representative goalie so if you
accept a donation of some material uh do
you have an obligation to keep
it thank you for your question so that
varies on donation to donation we have a
deed of gift agreement another policy I
had updated this year um which deter
based on the donor agreement between me
and the donor whether we would keep it
in perpetuity whether you know if I go
through it and decide we already have
several duplicates of these materials
and I can throw it away or give it back
to the donor it really varies on the
materials and the donor whether they
want it back or if it'll be disposed of
followup follow up so this is going to
the uh the positions who said higher
labor grade are these um salary
positions hourly
these are hourly positions okay thank
you other questions yeah just sorry to
clarify these are salaried positions
they're just very entry
level
fulltime okay representative laus
yeah yeah I was wondering if these are
ones that are going to have to be uh
classified and the joint committee on
employee classification is going to be
seen
sorry could you I couldn't hear your
question um if these are a salary the
question is I would expect but you can
let me know that um that the the salary
grade you're looking for or the um is
something that would be would go to the
Joint Committee on employee
classification so I was just going to
verify if that's true which reviews all
of
those um in the past our office has come
to this committee to um request labor
grade changes and so that's the route we
chose to go this
time
okay we'll have to do the Dirty Work
representative
laus the Dirty Work yes any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you for your testimony thank you is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on House Bill
1433 seeing none I will close the
hearing representative goalie that gives
you a chance to go down and get the
amendment which we will have to do
before we vote on this
bill excellent thank
you all
right
okay
all
right the next hearing is at 2 o'clock
so we have a short
break
well well they talk for at least 15
minutes we'd have time to vote on it but
not allowed to the
amendment
they
scheduling
right it's being 2 o'cl I'm opening the
hearing for House Bill 1095 and I call
Representative
Gallagher hi I'm representative Eric
Gallagher representing Marat County
District 20 which is conquered w six um
down that ways a little ways um and I'm
here to introduce HB 1095 relative to
the official pronunciation of New
Hampshire and conquered so um first
thing I'd note is just which portion of
the rsas this is going in this is going
in RSA Section 3 which is the state
symbol section so it's the kind of thing
where there's the state animal um state
insect butterfly fruit all that sort of
thing um so yeah just as with the other
state symbols um e for example even
though the state fruit is the pumpkin
you can still grow other fruits besides
pumpkins which I'm sure our Apple
Growers appreciate so um since I'm
putting it in the state symbol section
um you know you can still feel free to
say Concord if you wish um but it's
basically just having it um put some
some having the pronunciation put
somewhere um official so that people can
know the right way to recognize this
basically the um the way I see RSA 3 is
basically the section for describing the
official branding of the State of New
Hampshire um basically these are the
symbols by which you'll recognize us and
branding is actually something that um a
lot of organizations take really
seriously and spend a lot of money on
like my college for example um spent a
large amount of money redesigning its
visual identity um so
and uh this here ra rather than being
visual is
auditory um
so uh yeah I have the correct
pronunciation here I looked up the um I
decided to put it in the International
Phonetic Alphabet so um that's what this
handout that I handed around is is all
the different
um characters that are in the
International Phonetic Alphabet um the
reason for that is because English with
just the plain Roman alphabet doesn't
actually have enough characters to
represent every particular sound that
that um humans can make with our mouths
um so people a few hundred years ago um
realized we needed a sort of standard
way that um to write sounds that could
represent every possible sound in every
possible language so they uh came up
with the international ftic alphabet um
so yeah it's used in reference works um
like like
dictionaries um singers will use it if
they have to sing in a language they
don't know um my um brother actually
recently got married and his wife is a
speech pathologist so they had to learn
um
IPA uh as part of her Speech Pathology
training um so yeah it's basically kind
of the standard um and then the idea is
by putting it in IPA so all right
actually this kind of gets to why I file
the bill in the first place but um I've
been studying Japanese recently and um
one of the things I've noticed so um
they've got a few different character
sets that they use
um so one one of them for foreign loan
words um
and it's um that one's called kataka and
is um also phonetically based and when I
saw how they had uh how in Japanese they
had decided to uh
transcribe conquered in New Hampshire I
um I was like wait this isn't how you
actually pronounce it it looked like
Concord and New Hampshire like with a
sticking a y in the New Hampshire so um
basically the idea here is um that we
update the IPA first and then any
speakers of languages that have um
fically based reading systems would then
also update their spelling of conquered
and New Hampshire to reflect the
pronunciation
um so yeah just some
um so yeah besides um Japanese um just
some other examples of where this could
uh come in useful uh with the first in
the nation presidential primary we got a
lot of presidential candidates visit
visiting um and they often have a hard
time figuring out how to pronounce
things so was just thinking this could
help them also um tell
marketers um when they put out phone
calls uh often get it wrong too um and
you heard with the Canadian Consul
General Bernard Jordan when she spoke
before us she mostly got it right but I
do remember one specific instance when
she said New
Hampshire um and so hopefully just
having this written down somewhere
official would help people preparing to
speak before us
um
so um yeah I I will um
admit that this is a um rather minor
thing to have a bill about um you know
one question is well what why are you
wasting your time on this bill when
there's other more important stuff um so
if I have a few responses to that
question um one would be well you could
also make that argument about anything
else that's already in RSA 3 um you know
why waste half time why waste time on
having a state fruit or something um and
also um it didn't actually take that
long uh and we're a part-time
legislature with 400 members so if you
multiply um the amount of time available
to any particular one of us by 400 the
amount of person hours that we have
available to us is kind of a lot and I
do actually have bills on more important
topics too this is one of 11 lsrs I
filed this year
um but I do kind of try when filing
bills to go for things that other people
aren't also legislating about you know a
lot of the other more important issues
The Trenches are already dug in um and
people have already made up their minds
about it but um with something uh more
minor uh like this then I think we can
have a chance to um bring people
together and
um actually pass some legislation
um and
um oh and one more question to address
um so yeah New Hampshire makes sense for
us to address as state since we're the
state legislature um I guess one
question to kind of preemptively answer
would be well why single out conquered
when there are these other place
locations names that also get
mispronounced and I think the reason
there is because conquer the state
capital um so you know if the state is
going to put its government here I think
we do kind of um deserve a little bit
more special consideration than
um some of the some of the other places
just because you know if you're telling
people oh you need to come testify at
the hearing and conquered like that's
kind of a state Affair since yeah the
state Governor is meeting here um and um
I also noticed um in my email I um I see
there's going to be a non-gain Amendment
about it I won't speak directly to that
but I will note that I just generally
would oppose any non- gerain amendments
on principle just because I don't think
it's
necessary um so with that all not take
questions oh actually wait no one more
thing um uh um that I wanted to mention
uh about the pronunciation um
so uh you some of you may know the
boners Matt and Luke boner who went to
basketball and Matt Bonner in particular
is known for having this shirt that says
I came I saw I conquered and like
conquered r as the state capital so that
pun that pun really only works if you
pronounce it
correctly um and also one more thing so
there are four concords in the United
States um besides the um one we're in
now there's also one in Massachusetts
North Carolina and California so I think
by um specifying the pronunciation of
ours specifically that should help
people tell them apart a little bit
better so maybe we won't get as many
people coming here asking where the
battlefield is um so
yeah that's what I have to say about
this bill and I'll take questions out
thank you um representative Shu has a
question and then representative Brown
thank you madam chair um I thank you for
explaining your motivation I was curious
about that but um I do have concerns um
I'm of a considerably older
generation and uh we have a lot of old
Yankee folks who still live in New
Hampshire and they pronounce it New
Hampshire and Conquer and I'm curious if
you discuss this idea with any of them
I'll tell you I'm fearful that some of
them may be offended if we mandated a
specific pronunciation that doesn't jive
with with their
Heritage well again it's not mandating
um it's not it's not saying that anyone
has to use this since it's going in the
state um symbol section so and yeah I
just compare this back to um some of the
other state symbols you know with the
state fruit um of choosing Pumpkins I'm
sure some apple farmers were offended by
that
um and um I mean I I did do some
research on this um to see um what's
already used in some places
um and yeah uh
that this is what I found when looking
it up um as part of my research
process thank you represent Brown uh
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my
question um RSA
331 at this time is the state spider so
I don't know if I will let number that
wrong or if I'm looking at it
incorrectly um yeah it may very well be
a numbering mistake I I just um yeah
this is just whatas drafted for me so if
the section needs to be renumbered then
I'm perfectly okay with that thank
you very good represent man py thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question um this will be a audio clip
that would be pronounced in fanatic with
the fanatic inter International fanatic
alphabet using that or is it just a
click just written in the
International Phonetic Alphabet well so
um yeah I mean since the way we do our
legislation still is primarily on paper
you can't really put audio clips onto
paper but I would think like um yeah um
that that this does actually kind of
bring up another reason I filed this
bill was um just to uh see if the
legislation software that OS uses could
render the characters properly um and I
think um what one kind of BR bigger
picture goal that I'd like to see
eventually is moving to digital native
legislating uh where you could include
things like um audio and stuff in the
legislation um and yeah if the state
wants to put an audio clip um on the
website um yeah to go with this then
yeah I would appreciate that but um as
long as we also have to have uh paper
copies as well then uh we need some sort
we need to be putting in some sort of
written format
okay other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony and thanks for having
me is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 1095
five seeing none I'll close the public
hearing and we will go into executive
session as agreed with representative
groa before she left on House Bill
1433 representative
goalie thank you madam chair I will move
a to pass um so that I can introduce an
amendment I get a second okay F and
schmi yes you your amendment is and I
move Amendment
H all right that to
age you to speak to your motion
representative Schmidt has
second thank you m chair um as we
heard currently um unlike a number of
other state agencies archives doesn't
have in statute the ability to accept
I'll speak to the amendment first I
apologize yeah that's okay um
first what the amendment does uh it
strikes out two stock clerk 2 positions
and makes them back to uh stock clerk
3 um as you heard one of the uh
positions is currently vacant um they're
having trouble filling these positions
and they're hoping with a um little bit
of a salary upgrade they can get these
positions filled um they're important
positions they're the ones that maintain
the stock and you know the clerks and
working in behind the scenes um so
they're hoping with this little salary
bump that they can get those position
that position filled um in doing so so
that's why they brought forward this
amendment all
right and despite the reference the
governor drawing out a warrant the
Secretary of State testified that they
had enough money in their budget to
cover it correct and they said that
would be roughly under $55,000 to cover
those two positions
okay representative man py thank you
madam chair So currently they do accept
but it's not done in a they do accept
donation we're talking about the
amendment right now
okay we'll get back back to the bill
after we just decide on the amendment
representative leus yeah just to make it
clear the 5,000 is the additional cost
because of the increase uh in the salary
range so they're getting rid of uh two
at a lower position and creating two at
a little higher and they said the total
for the two positions is around
5,000
okay
yes Brown thank you madam chair so I I
don't know if representative goalie
knows this I probably should have asked
the the folks that were
here these two positions are needed to
handle the extra work in receiving
donations
no
no there are turn two current these two
current positions are in place this
removes those two positions creates two
new positions at a higher grade okay so
as a followup followup it's almost two
separate
issues yes thank you thank
you so I hope this is considered a
Germain Amendment but representative
laus right I think the as I understand I
think the point was at the current
salary range they have not been able to
fill the positions and they're hoping to
be able to do
so yeah they're they're hoping that
there would be more uh more donations
coming in but one never
knows anyone
else all right we'll uh we'll see if we
if it's judged non but it looks pretty
germine to me
so all right anyone
else okay in that case the motion is
madam chair yes that's that's not what
it was meaning at
all that it was non gerain I didn't mean
that but that's not okay well that's
fine it is you know only marginally
related to the original bill at best
okay I'm trying to to run this as an
educational opportunity for
okay so the motion is to accept
Amendment
0662 and the clerk can call the role
representative zimon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Dolan yes clerk votes yes
representative voyd yes representative
Brown yes representative Schmidt no
problem representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes represent gold
yes representative mapy yes and the
chair yes 13 y z n okay we've adopted
the amendment representative goalie
you're moving ought to pass through the
amendment and representative Schmid
seconds
okay any further uh
discussion repres golden thank you madam
chair I was starting to State a little
ahead of my self that this just gives uh
them the ability to do what most other
state agencies currently do now and this
codifies it into statute to accept those
donations and goods okay there's a man
yeah so just to follow with that so
currently they do accept they do have it
but may put it in the statute so it
becomes official is what we're doing
okay thank you representative gold as as
I understand there are some statutes
that require required various agencies
to put their records there but this is
just giving them the ability officially
to accept them so the previous behaviors
haven't been outside of legislation
always but well but I'm sure they have
donations from private parties and so
forth that they've accepted as being
relevant
but when the new
archivist found out that the weren't
they weren't
authorized to do
so yeah exactly all right any does
anyone else have a comment
representative schmidth I should have
got you soon so I mean
the the situation has been that they
were obviously occasionally given things
donated things and so forth they
accepted them because seemed normal
natural and so forth but it was always a
situation where somebody would say would
well what's the deal with that people
would go well that's perfectly
obvious we have all kinds of things in
statutes like addresses where things get
sent and every once in a while that
address goes out of currency and so
forth and then we have to change the
statute to either take the an address
out or to correct the address but it has
to be changed because otherwise it's
wrong in the statute so it's strictly
ministerial but that's what makes more
sense to have it resolved rather than
well it's
obvious exactly and any other comments
questions okay the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill 1433
and
the representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Dolan yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
Schmidt yes repres representative goalie
yes representative Shu yes
representative Gould yes representative
manip py yes and the chair yes 13 y0 n
okay the motion passes is there any
objection to
consent seeing none we'll put it on
consent representative goalie uh you
could get ited fairly soon I'd
appreciate
it all
right and I would like to go on to the
other simple one which is how cacr
11 does someone have a motion on that
I'll move uh to
pass all
right is there a
second
okay second representative
Brown
okay it seems to me that this bill makes
a lot of sense in terms
of those candidates who are holding a an
elected position who whose age is going
to change during the course of their um
their current
engagement they're prevented from
continuing on beyond the the age limit
because they cannot run for real
election so it's it's a matter of a year
or two to let somebody finish out their
term and it makes sense to me
representative Brown you wish to comment
on a second no
okay representative Schmidt and then
Dolan and then Son thank you ordinarily
I would have seconded this this cacr
motion but um I I deferred specifically
and I would speak to it and that is in
straford County we currently have an
acting
Sheriff U because I'm sure many of you
are aware of the very disgraceful
situation with former High Sheriff Mark
Brave um he uh was put into a an
administrative U leave situation at the
urging of the at the urging of the
Commissioners because he really
shouldn't have
been carrying out the function of the
sheriff given his legal issues uh and
the department was in so bad shape um
and um so the Commissioners got him to
accept this administrative leave and and
uh one of the able members of the law
enforcement in Stafford County step
forward to to become the acting sheriff
and that was fine as long as uh as long
as everything was kind of like in
suspended animation there but then When
U Mark Brave moved out of state that
issue came up what what are the
qualifications you have to live in the
county and he actually moved out of the
state and paid his next year's rent in
advance that kind of suggest a certain
long-term plan right um and and at that
point they said now you now you're you
have to
resign uh and so when he did now the the
delegation has to elect in the
circumstance has to elect the
replacement because that's what the
statute requires uh and the individual
involved is the only person who applied
for the position so we're going to be
electing him but the point is he's going
to turn 70 on October
24th so that means that under the law
when October if we do elect him which
we'll do in a week or so when when when
October 24th become comes so along he's
automatically out there will be no
Sheriff you know he doesn't have to
resign he's just gone okay now for a
week which is what it will be until the
next election nobody's will have an
somebody will act for for that week but
the point is that um here's somebody
who's eminently qualified who's doing an
excellent job we're going to elect him
to be Sheriff he's only going to
have 10 months or so in office uh but in
the case of Rockham County where they
have a four-year term Sheriff MOS I
think he pronounces it um he he here
gave a gave us a good reason why it's
not a good idea to have them
automatically removed from office the
moment they turn 70 and and we're also
at a point where 70 ain't no age at all
for most
people I'm going like 70-year-old nice
young
man okay representative Dolan I wave you
wave off okay representative Simon and
then laus thank you madam chair um in
principle according to the testimony
heard I'm not sure that I'm opposed to
the bill I just want to make sure I
understand completely what it is that
we're voting on um so and it's part of
my ignorance on this but who determines
the length of term for these positions
it's in statute it's in statute so it
would have to come through us for a law
change CU once we change it we could
theoretically anyway change the length
of the term and somebody could start at
age 69 and we change it to a 10-year
term and they could stay in until they
were 79 um because there is a hard line
like there's a hard line in this
particular
constitutional statute or the
Constitution so uh I do have maybe a
little bit of a concern about that but
um it being in statute at least it would
have to come through us I suppose not
nine of the sheriffs serve twoyear terms
and one serves a four-year
term representative leus and then sh it
yeah I mean I don't feel strongly but I
I really don't like this um partly the
concern that rep Simon raised U and I'd
have less of a concern if in the
amendment it said to two years but uh
the other part of it is you this is I
know it applies in other cases but at
this point we're basically not only
making a bill but proposing a
constitutional amendment for the moment
one person and I'm I'm not terribly fond
of that but um I may vote against I
don't know but if I certainly wouldn't
object to consent if that's the
consensus I don't believe cacs can go on
consent anyway right sorry
representative Shu thank you madam chair
um I'll just point out I think we're all
aware of the um shortage in law
enforcement officers in the state and
the pool of people who run for Sheriff
are traditionally um I say retired
officers or retired sheriff's deputies
which automatically moves them into an
older category so I think just making
this concession and and for all the
counties except one currently it would
just be like another year basically
added uh that they would be eligible to
serve so I'm in favor of
this okay repres represent gold I would
just quickly respond to represent
Simon's concern that certainly if there
was a a bill to lengthen the term that
the issue of the age could be taken up
at that time you know both things could
happen lengthen the term and put that
hard stop
in okay same folks as always
representative Manti thank you Madame CH
Mike I was just surprised to see that
the sheriff need not be of law
enforcement and anybody can do so it's
just opens it up for anyone who is 69 or
70 and can have it as a retirement job
so yes representative
uh
Schmid okay so so the issue is that
whether you like it or not and we in
represent Le's position is uh is is
worth some discussion uh I didn't want
to get into before but but I was aware
of this thing and that is not so much
that we're doing it for one person but
but we're doing a Constitutional
Amendment which means this is citizenry
is going to be called on to make this
change by a 2third vote right uh and and
and the question becomes the age aspect
or the whether you say a person should
have some qualifications but it's a it's
a political office it's an elective
office and now the county sheriff is
also an elective office but there there
are
qualifications uh no this is the county
sheriff what sorry I meant to say that I
if I didn't say it right the County
Attorney is an elected position as well
the register of deeds is a an elected
position um and but with a county
attorney there are some qualifications
with Sheriff the only one is you have to
be under 70 currently and you have to
live in the county so it's worth
discussing whether we want to go forward
with the idea of making a constitutional
change I think we should deliberate
about that a little bit more Madam chair
going to the time I move the question
well I think we will postpone this we've
raised a lot of issues and I think we
should
uh I think it would be quicker if we
went on to the next
bill I'll withdraw the motion so we no
no no we'll just recess until after
we've dealt
with which I hope since there's only one
person to speak it won't be too long all
right so clo closing the executive
recessing the executive session open the
hearing on cacr 21 and call
Representative
yella thank you thank you madam chair
and members of the
committee um I am here to introduce cacr
21 um relative to the oath of City
officers
um
the the the resolution proposes a
critical provision asserting that the
default oath of office shall be
non-religious uh government should
strive to be neutral in matters of
religion treating all citizens equally
regardless of their religious beliefs a
non-religious oath helps maintain this
neutrality and prevents the perception
of favoritism towards religion over
non-religious
people um Gallop found in 2015 that only
20% of New Hampshire residents consider
themselves to be very religious um Many
religious people would um have no issue
under using the words uh swear under
penalty of perjury in their oath and so
I believe this change will overall
reduce the number of people quote
refusing Oaths so that they can get the
other um
oath I believe that adopting a
non-religious oath as a default option
is uh commendable a step towards
guaranteeing inclusiveness by no longer
assuming that the by default that
members believe in God um by eliminating
religious references in the default oath
we make uh religious Expressions
separate from governmental functions
um the normal state of government while
still keeping the
option uh of the alternate oath for
those who really want to swear to God um
this this Constitutional Amendment
aligns with the fundamental principles
of equal representation representation
and holds the cherish value of the separ
of church and state um this amendment
will send a strong message to our uh the
people
that our government is committed to
recognizing and respecting the diversity
of its citizens um as an atheist I
requested an uh an oath of office the
first time when I swore in as a
representative um but I would say more
often than not when I get sworn in I
forget to uh
refuse and they hand me a piece of paper
that says I swear to God and I have to
make a decision in that moment of
whether or not I'm going to make a big
deal out of it and since most of my
elected positions have been at the Town
Office it's my town clerk that would
have to be like run up and get another
new piece of paper and all of that and
I uh have not made her go do that extra
work and so
um I just think that it it makes sense
like every time I I get sworn in I uh
under the wrong oath or or oath swearing
to God I I find it ironic that that we
still have that be the default in the
state of New Hampshire or in the country
in general uh that swearing to God
instead of just under penalty of perjury
so I hope you will uh support the change
of that switch of the default not
eliminating any any options just
changing the default to the
non-religious um oath of office so thank
you and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you are there any
questions represent
Schmid thank you madam chair um so I'm
not aware of any of any oath where where
it's where the wording is I swear to God
I believe the Oaths I've all taken all
said I swear or affirm some people don't
like to use the word swear I I swear or
affirm that I was am not swearing to God
although the words so help me God are
present in this particular document uh
and I have a question about that after
somebody else has a shot but um so I'm
I'm I am a little bit puzzled by the
first several instances the words so
help me God are struck struck and um is
substitute oath and pains of P penalties
of perjury I think it's worthy of
discussion and then later on is that
language is struck and it's substituted
for so help me God so why they why the
once into the woods onto the one hand
and out of the woods on the other hand
so thank you for the question so the the
first two are the
default where I'm striking it in on line
six to seven and and 10 to 11 I'm
striking out that is what is normally
given if you
don't
refuse um that's what is given to
everyone right and if you
refuse
um then comes in this this
second part of the the of the uh oath
which says
um that if anyone is scrupulous of
swearing shall decline from taking the
said oath and then they admit the words
that you have an issue with and
substitute the other words and so if you
have a issue with I swear under penalty
of perjury you can then switch to just
eliminate the word swear for certain
denominations and and and uh switch to
uh so help me God instead of the
standard okay thank you absolutely B VI
Kella are you aware that this
constitutional change would not apply to
town
offices if you look on line three town
officers are explicitly Exempted from
the
oath thank you for the question I do see
that it and and
so um
that's I guess that wouldn't mean that a
a change for Town off officers would not
require a constitutional amendment and
so I I don't think it should be combined
with this bill um since it has a this
bill has a higher standard to get passed
great okay thank you for that thank you
representative
dlan thank you madam chair I'm just
pulled out a $10 bill out of my wallet
and and I'm looking at the top at the
back of the bill and the right above the
flag it says In God We Trust do do you
believe that this change is going to put
us at odds with things such as our our
currency that we use repes
representative
Dolan I you shouldn't question his
motives that
way I didn't
understand I think
I agree that it's a federal that that
the the money is a federal issue and not
a state issue at this
time thank you anyone
else okay thank you for your testimony
thank you is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on
ca21 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing
and we will resume our executive session
on cacr
11 and as I represent Simon I think you
are on
day oh
yes you got a backtrack in my thinking
to where we were at
um I'm not sure actually U I was going
to respond to representative G's comment
that we could um put a hard line in
um I mean technically if we were to
change the um the term limits on these
positions which aren't just in this bill
I believe it's it's not just pertaining
to sheriffs it would also be pertaining
to judges um because judges are included
if I'm in this part of the Constitution
or so any judge of court judge of
probate or Sheriff of any County after
the person has attained the age of 70 oh
no it switches to sheriff right yep it's
the this is specific to Sheriff's okay
never mind on that point um but it
wouldn't I mean we could set a we could
set our the age obviously by the term
that we give to the sheriff um but then
a subsequent um subsequent legislature
could switch that age to another age so
it doesn't create a hard line um at any
particular point in time I'm not saying
that the a future legislature would um
be irresponsible or you know um anything
of that nature I'm not going to question
future people's motives that way or
abilities but um just wanted to say I'm
not sure that it actually does create a
Hardline with obviously maintains
control through the legislature but
um yeah that was
it okay representative Shu you had a
comment I decided not to I was I was
going to say speaking as an
octogenarian uh 70 doesn't seem that
whole
okay yes representative Bailey and I'm
not entirely sure this is gerain but
representative
uh Schmidt asked or or said that we
would be electing a new sheriff sometime
soon who who's we is that a is that a
general election or is it stord County
delegation you and I then are the ones
long Us in the room that will be doing
this I'm not sure I'm comfortable with
that uh but okay thank you you remember
you remember we elected County attorne
okay representative Brown did you have a
comment yeah thank you madam chair
following up on uh representative Shu
said something about one year
actually you could be 74 years 11 months
and 30 days
old when you get elected yes that's how
long you could be in if you were elected
a day before your birthday and rock M
what's that just rock and rock yes and
that count and and follow up yeah follow
up and and a couple people have said
this but it it uh um it seems like a a
oneoff and when you take the job as
Sheriff you know when it ends and if you
you haven't finished your your goals and
that is kind of how life goes sometimes
I
think ran black us thank you yeah for
that reason I'm going to and also
because uh the this is a limit in the
con
stitution um but it can be gotten around
I'm not saying legisl would do it but we
could legislature could set the maximum
term to 70 years or something and
basically make this thing null and so
unless there were a maximum um term
they're elected at in this amendment as
well I'd have to oppose it okay
representative sh thank you madam chair
leave us not forget that all this really
does is puts it to the voters to see if
they want to agree with it or not
y okay well I'd like to say that I'm
very uncomfortable legislating for one
person which is what it seems to be and
I'm not in support of this
amendment all right anyone else comments
question representative
G I've heard several several of you talk
about that it's only for one person but
yet representative Schmidt is telling us
about a second and it really is about
anybody who and and as we've talked
about
that
repres excuse me representative Shu
expressed that is generally
retirees so um I think that just because
one person who came forward and
testified is experiencing it we should
look at this as something that could
affect any candidate and it isn't really
only about woman
candidate okay thank you thank you any
anyone else
comments
questions okay in that case the motion
is ought to pass on
cacr 11 and the clerk can call the
RO representative Simon no
Representative lakas no representative
Bailey no representative
Dolan
you know clerk Voz representative voy no
representative Brown
no representative
Schmidt no representative
goalie
no did I did I miss you oh you're back
sorry I was that I'd scratch you off
from when you were I apologize
representative gr no no representative
sht
yes representative G
yes representative Manti no and the
chair
no so we have 10 yay uh four four yes uh
four yes sorry 10
nay okay
the so that's four in favor 10 opposed
and the motion fails does someone have
an alternate motion I'll move
itl all right is there a
second okay move by representative broa
second by representative leus do you
wish to speak to your motion well from
when I understand you guys have talked
about this enough so I think we're ready
to vote all right represent leus I agree
anyone
else okay seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate by
representative GR the clerk can call the
role represent representative Simon
yes representative Lakers yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Dolan
no clerk roads
no representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
Gro yes representative Smidt yes
representative goalie yes
Representative sht
no representative Gould
no representative Mani
yes and the chair yes tene
for
okay Madame chair I'd like to apologize
referring to my committee mates as guys
I apologize that will bear it's very
sloppy
okay the motion passes 10 to4 uh does
someone wish to write a Minority
Report okay um so we we'll put Diane
down in for the Minority
Report it will be on the regular
calendar in any case so I think we're
okay y I'll take
respons okay
you all right you will write a minor
report of
school all
right
um it'd be really nice to get in the
calendar which is tomorrow we'll
do
so uh yeah I don't think we can go on to
the one of the
others no no all right we'll take a
break until 3 pm when we will take up
with our last bill of the
day that
uh well I've got a
330 but uh one down is a good start at
least no
right
all right welcome back I'm opening the
hearing on House Bill 1016 and call
Representative
Mel yeah
thank you madam chair good
afternoon members of Edna it's nice to
be here for the first time that I I
believe it's my first time here so it's
really nice to see everybody and
hopefully finish out the day with a bill
that's a little lighter than some of the
topics that we
get um I've been told that this bill is
a talker talker over the Thanksgiving
table and around Christmas and everybody
seems to have an opinion on it which can
make it kind of
fun so I just want to talk a tiny bit
about some of the history Jonathan
Robinson Ebenezer Hawkins and David leay
wrote to General Stark in the spring of
1810 and the letter is here actually uh
you can see it on the Historical Society
this is the full letter and it's our
best known recollection and recording of
our actual monitor or motto they said
the toast sir which you sent in 1809
will continue to vibrate with unending
pleasure in our ears Live Free or Die
death is not the greatest of
evils so these were the famous words
penned by penned by General Stark
commemorating the Battle of Bennington
of course he's known as the hero of
Bennington
and they have continued to reverberate
across New Hampshire for many many years
1945 became it landed on our our state
emblem and became our state motto 1969
we put it on the license plate and then
some 30 years later some
young naive 20-some sponsored a house
resolution in
1999 to put it on the state quarter and
that was me that was this legislator
with uh then representative
lerno Senator Hollingsworth and a few
others it was a bipartisan effort to
enshrine Live Free or Die Forever on our
United States currency representing our
state so since then it never really
occurred to me to put it on the
flag until I went to
ncsl last year and I thought well I've
been gone a long time as a returning
member there's an awful lot of members
here that I don't know you see at at
ncsl you get one of the those big fancy
credentials and they not only put your
name and somewhere they put your state
but they put a little tiny version of
your state flag so if you take a look at
the second page the committee Services
was kind enough to make some color
copies for me you can see all the
different flags in the that's in this
chart um that has the red you know the
the beautiful great good boring these
that ratings down towards the bottom you
see all the ones that are considered
boring and they are affectionately
referred to as blue bed sheets with a
state seal and I didn't come up with
that so you know we're a great state
without a great flag I mean we're
incredibly unique in so many ways and
everybody knows Live Free or Die across
the country I mean I can't get on an
airplane go to another city and tell
them I'm from New Hampshire without
saying without having someone say oh the
Live Free or Die
State people like to be like us but they
can't recognize our flag so I looked
into how many other times this has been
tried and the most recent time was House
Bill 123 sponsored by our own house
clerk then representative Paul
Smith also with one of my co-sponsors
then Senator lerno and their idea was to
put Old English script in some scroll
work and it was rather
complex and it arguably was difficult to
read as this this could be also actually
so um that went to a floor fight and
narrowly failed actually it wasn't uh
that was about I want to say it was
2017 something like that so it's been
tried a few times before there's been
bills to radically redesign everything
um you know have a contest the conquered
monitor had wrote an article about
having high school design students
there's been a lot of discussion about
this over the years so why now and why
should we do this well first of all um
about six eight other states have
already done something similar they've
done more dramatic redesigns Maine is in
the final stages of
adoption um so why don't we just have a
whole redesign have a newspaper contest
have a commissioner committee well all
of those things kind of make me chuckle
that's an awful lot of cooks and could
be a difficult pill for the
traditionalists to accept taking the
Raleigh off the flag I mean there's a
lot of history in our state seal
but I will tell you that Having learned
about the basic rules of flag design our
flag well first of all rule number one
is you will never please anyone right
universally you just will not some of
the other rules are things like don't
put a state seal on a flag some other
ones are don't put any text on a flag so
yes I'm suggesting our flag violate one
more rule by putting text on it but it
is such unique text Live Free or Die
death is not the greatest of evils we
hear it as death is not the worst of
evils there are worse evils than death
but I assure you the most historically
accurate is death is not the greatest of
evils so the first part live for or die
I just believe in my core belongs on our
flag so we don't get confused with all
the other blue bed sheets so how do we
do it well it's pretty simple um we roll
it out over five years so that we use up
our stock of exist Flags any flag
manufacturer like Anon or any of the
other big ones Anon is the big boy uh
will happily prepare a flag for us at no
cost you know they won't charge us like
a setup fee or something like that if
they did it'd be 100 hundred bucks but
they won't do it anyways because they're
going to sell plenty of Flags uh when we
add Live Free or Die to it so it's
pretty much that simple I've given you
my written testimony there's a few other
historical tidbits in there like how we
ranked 63rd out of 71 flags of North
American states and territories that
included some from Canada they've got
some boring flags up there too so we
were 63rd out of 71 which is pretty bad
um but there's at least 20 States whose
flags look just like ours and you know
what that's long enough it's long enough
it has been our flag for over a hundred
years and this time we add Live Free or
Die to
it all right thank you for your
testimony I'd like to mention that your
proposed redesign would not take us out
of the boring category because Montana
and Kansas already haveing to say which
which state they're in on their blue bed
sheets so are there any questions from
the committee slightly less boring
maybe and somewhat more
recognizable but yes you are correct we
would actually violate one additional
rule of flag design and I will also
mention I think I said in my written
testimony um I've been uh regaled with
literally hundreds of design suggestions
for complete redesign one of which is
sitting behind me a lovely gentleman
who's 12 years old and I will let him
speak for himself because he is more
than
capable um but there have been an awful
lot of suggestions for complete
redesigns and personally I think that's
a great idea as long as it includes Live
Free or Die but my legislative
experience tells me that there may not
be the political will for such a radical
departure from tradition so baby steps
and I don't anticipate asking to fully
redesign it five years from now if you
do this thank you anyone else have a
question all right seeing none
representative
Corman thank you madam chair I'm Tom
Corman I represent Grafton 15 which is
Ward three of the city of Lebanon and I
agree with representative MCU that our
flag could use Improvement um and it's
true it's a lot like a lot of the other
flags there's a very entertaining video
that you can find where uh the flags are
actually put into various categories a
through F minus ours is I think F minus
or maybe just F but it's it's down in
the bottom
tier I actually was thinking of
submitting a bill on the state flag this
year uh in consultation with
representative MCU I decided to wait a
year and and let his bill process
through the bill that I would uh have
presented would have been about a study
commission about the flag that would
have included somebody from the state
his historical society and somebody from
the new England vexillological
Association for those who don't know
vexillology is the study of flags and in
fact I have here good flag bad flag a
guide to flag design or how to design a
great flag put out by the North American
Vex olical
society and they have the principles of
flag design number one keep it simple
the flag should be so simple that a
child can draw it from memory so a great
example would be say Texas a star
in a blue background couple of
Stripes use meaningful
symbolism uh so of course we have the
Raleigh which is actually in the state
seal and um I would posit that if you
were to randomly ask a thousand New
Hampshire residents tell me something
about the boat on the flag I doubt more
than 10% could tell you anything about
the boat on the flag including its name
number three use two or three basic
colors well our flag has a lot of
different colors on it number four no
lettering or Seals All right we fail on
that not only do we have the seal but
the seal has lettering that says seal of
the State of New Hampshire and then of
course this proposal is to add more text
which representative MCU admits it it
violates that rule uh one of the things
about text is it is hard to read even
text the that that representative muu
has proposed with specific size and a
specific font it can be hard to read and
also on the reverse side of a flag it
would just be Mirror Image unless the
flag is somehow uh printed on both sides
and number five be distinctive or be
related avoid duplicating other flags
but use similarities to show connections
so of course we are just like these
other flags it certainly isn't unique
so I I just feel like if we take our
current flag and add text to it we're
taking a I hate to say but a bad flag
and we're making it worse so I'll
conclude with
that thank you for the for your
testimony representative leus has a
question yeah I'll just ask if you you
could send the uh information from that
that you had there on uh flag design and
just send a link to it to the committee
i' I'd be happy to do that and if I can
track down that video I'll send the link
to that as well all right thank
you any other uh
questions thank you for your
testimony Andrew
flockton
good afternoon Madame chair and members
of the
committee I am Andrew flockton of
Milford and a member of the North
American vexillological Association
which studies Flags I am testifying in
support of house bail 1016 specifically
an amendment by representative Dunn
proposing my design for the state flag
of New
Hampshire I thank representative MCU for
his
testimony and I think that the current
state flag of New Hampshire basically
consists of the state seal on a blue
background commonly called a seal on a
bed sheet the people of New Hampshire
helped me decide what to put on this
flag this speech will tell you why these
symbols are on my flag and why I think
the state flag should be changed firstly
The Old Man of the Mountain is a
distinct symbol to both new hampshirites
and people
Nationwide The Old Man of the Mountain
is synonymous with New Hampshire it is
on the state emblem license plates State
Route signs and the New Hampshire State
quarter
The Motto Live Free or Die is a
synonymous symbol featured on our state
emblem and license plates this flag
would give the old man representation on
flag polls across the state this flag
also includes Live Free or Die our state
motto famously ran by General John Stark
in
1809 there are also Nine Stars
representing New Hampshire being the
ninth state admitted to the
union secondly two states have recently
changed their seal on a bed sheet Flags
Utah and
Minnesota I think that the design I'm
proposing would be a unique symbol of
New Hampshire the New Hampshire flag is
one of 33 that Ed their state seal or
coat of arms on their flag and one of
the 25 flags with a blue
background in the 2001 State and
provincial flag survey by the North
American vexillological Association a
New Hampshire rank 63rd or in other
words the 10th worst flag in the
survey that is why I argue that if New
Hampshire's flag has changed it may be a
better and more effective flag to
represent New Hampshire I have spoken
with flag experts and shown them my
design they seem to like the Old Man of
the
Mountain a simple design with FL with
few colors and no state seal the state
seal is disliked by both vexillologists
and New Hampshire
citizens the
vexillologists the
people the vexillologists would like a
simple
flag although none of the vists are from
New Hampshire they were swayed when I
educated them on the symbolism of the
old man and Live Free or Die the people
of New Hampshire that I've talked to
like the flag that incorporates The Old
Man and live for your die you can see
both the
vexillologists and the People's Choice
on a slideshow I have submitted to this
committee you may wonder how many people
visit the beautiful White Mountains in
which the old man was nestled well
according to the forest service the
White Mountains receives upwards of six
million visitors annually there is a
field of white on my flag to represent
the White Mountains
a large majority of these vors visitors
understand the symbolism that the old
man represents for New Hampshire and as
far as Live Free or Die General Stark
wrote this as a toast to the Battle of
Bennington a battle which helped America
on his quest for Independence the fall
quote is actually Live Free or Die death
is not the greatest of evils New
Hampshire is a state that fought to
secure the FRS we all enjoy today
putting Live Free or Die on the flag
serves as a commemoration to our state's
history and the freedoms we all enjoy
today everyone what do you think of when
you think of New Hampshire what I think
about is the old man and live for your
die both great symbols of the great
Granite State as you may see my shirt as
my design this will give you an idea of
the flag that I
propose I thank the chair and the
committee members for their
time
thank you and if you could stand up
again so so that the slower people can
take a look at it blue and white with
the old man and live for or die okay and
The Nine Stars Behind the old man okay
thank
you much much more visible than referes
M's Choice all right any do we have any
questions for Mr flockton
no well thank you very much for your uh
testimony and your flag design will take
will
considerate thank
you okay does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill
106 all right seeing none I will close
the
hearing
and
what you like it that
or1
you
okay Madam chair I have a question yes
since we've heard at least three
pronunciations of the sponsor's name uh
this this afternoon I'd like to have and
I've and the last letters of your name
you know I think of the word rough
through though
thou Etc
that please what do you say thank you
it's it's muu muu MCG u e your I see the
Irish of course have mangled the
spelling
sure
okay thank you so much all
right close the hearing on House Bill
1016 and I'd like to open an executive
session on cacr
21 which is the oath of civil
officers does someone have a motion
representative groda yes hi um I mean
yes yes Madam chair I move itl on cacr
21 second seconded by uh representative
gold all right do you wish to speak to
your motion yes um I think the majority
I don't want to generalize but we are
this what we have now is working and if
somebody doesn't want to use the word
God they can opt out for that and I
don't want that option to be the opt in
option right I want our oath to be the
oped in the one that's always there and
if you don't want to have it you can
choose something
else thank
you representative bu do you wish to
speak to yourself I'll just add I I
agree with everything representative
grotus said and I will just add that um
my faith causes me to to um not swear an
oath and so I choose the affirmation
when it seems worth bothering somebody
and so I understood the argument um in
terms of the discomfort of asking for an
alternative and having to think about it
and all that but we are all different
and we do have options and the majority
likes what we have so I I and did this
itl all right representative go leus and
then Dolan okay I'm going to support the
itl even though um I do pick the
alternate oath um
but you know I I would I would see that
if we went to propose this it might be
perceived
maybe as the sponsor thought or maybe
not uh but there could be problematic
perceptions and I don't see it as a big
problem and so I'm fine with the itail
okay represent Dolan thank you madam
chair uh I I object to
the the uh the tendency that we have in
society now to try to chase anything
religious out of our lives or out of our
uh daily processes I have a a a little
bit of data from the Pew Research Center
that says that people who are high
highly religious are more engaged with
their extended families more likely to
be Volunteers in their Community more
involved in their community and
generally happier with the way their
lives are going so I I think that we
should uh try to retain as much
traditional uh religious value that we
have and and I I will be voting
itl anyone else have a comment
question okay in that case the motion is
in expedien to legislate on cacr
21 CL and call the
rooll representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey
no representative Dolan
yes clerk vote
Yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative SMI Schmid yes
I apologize to both of them I apologize
representative goalie yes representative
Shu
yes representative G yes represent Manti
yes and the chair
yes 13A One
n okay motion passes resent ba do you
wish to write write a Minority Report
all right this will be on the regular
calendar no
objection well I don't think cacs go on
on
consent 131
what oh okay well in that case is there
any objection to
consent oh yeah
it's could well sorry I was
corrected so if no one objects we'll put
it on
consent okay seeing
none all
right do think we should take up the
flag or
not what
yeah
okay um on House Bill
1016 does someone have a
motion I'll make a motion to itl House
Bill
second all
right you wish to speak to your
motion I don't believe that the
legislature should be making this
decision if we want to change the flag
we should let it be and we should have
the our constituents involved in
whatever way that happens so although
maybe our flag is boring I never
considered it boring frankly but that's
you know apparently the opinion of
people who study Flags um
but Beauty is in the eye of the the
beholder for me and um I don't see a
reason that we need to to uh pass this
bill okay represent gold I agree with
everything representative groa just said
and I not that long ago studied it
myself when there was a big H hbla
around the country about Native
Americans on state flags and how they
were depicted and was very thankful that
we didn't have that to contend with so
so I I I just agree this is not it's not
an issue I think I loved the young man's
presentation you know if the public
wants to get involved and do something
creative yay I agree yes representative
laus yeah well I uh I strongly would
like to see lrey die on the flag um I
agree that you know probably needs a a
more General redo and I'm not sure Edna
is the best place to make that decision
although if I had to vote for one or the
other I probably would have voted for
the the young fellow who
testified yes representative Simon and
then sure it thank you madam chair yeah
I agree I'd love to see Li three or die
on it but I do have this small concern
that when it's flapping in the breeze
it'll just say die um and so that does
concern me a little bit all right
representative
Shu thank you oh well as a trivia
wonk I like having just what's there if
you make it too too obvious then more
people are going to know an answer if
someone refers to that right now that
I've I've actually um had the question
what's the name of the ship on that and
most people don't know it's the Raleigh
but I
do that's where we
are thank you madam chair and I think
the young man uh who presented will be a
rep when he comes up here and say okay
I'm going to introduce a bill to change
the flag but it was really interesting
how they young folks in the state are
taking interest and maybe something the
fourth graders will take
up representative
Bailey I guess I'm going to be alone
again I'm going to Pander to the vexi
olist
vote well the Vex
vist say that this read Des L makes a
bad flag bet worse so I'm go with the
experts thank you for that thank you for
[Laughter]
that all right anyone else J Madam it's
a good way of ending the day with a lot
of laughter and fun representative
Schmid oh we have a a four o'clock
appointment at the dental Society uh
annual bash so don't talk too long
Peter so I have 30 minutes to burn uh
but but I agree with the initial
statement was made it probably shouldn't
be made by this committee like that I
think the young man has whether he came
up with it on on his own or with the
help of anybody else is irrelevant to me
but he's got an opportunity to to Market
that design which I think would sell a
lot of flags or pendants or whatever U
but I think it really should be if we're
going to take it up it should be taken
up by experts and give the people a
choice not however brilliant we might be
to make a have it be done by us um so uh
I I I'll vote itl but um I'll agree with
representative schmith that despite our
Brilliance we haven't shown large
quantities of artistic
talent well we haven't had a contest to
do that yet
um I'll I'll compete in that one uh so
anyway okay let's get get on to the Del
Delta Dental bash thank you anyone else
all right seeing no no further
conversation the motion is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
1016 and cl can all the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakus yes representative Bailey no is
not the worst of
evils representative
Dolan the clerk votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative Brown
no representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Gould yes
representative
mapy yes and the chair yes 12 Y 2
nay okay motion passes 12-2 does anyone
object to
consent all right then we'll put this
one on
consent
and what's
that no the the we have a non- gerain
amendment that will fix that
one in the terms of last you fix your
dog yes all right I think that's
representative
Dolan uh tomorrow we are meet we are
meeting in our own room for I think it's
six or seven bills public hearings as
usual we exec any of that appear to be
obvious at starting at 10:00 yes
Thursday we're in
session hear what you what I wanted to
hear what
you
okay is
1337 going to subcommittee what is 1337
going to
subcommittee there 87 no um I'm sorry
yes 87
um it might as well along with the other
one I don't think I want to do it today
it it would take too long yeah and the
shrimp would be all
gone all right
M closing our uh public hear our
executive session and I'll see you
tomorrow